Hello, everybody!
Ooh, I'm not supposed to show that screen yet.
You have two more minutes till we can.
Also, I just realized...
Professional streamer here.
Let me...
Yeah, I just like...
I don't know how I have so much energy.
I don't know.
Yesterday, I think I streamed for like 11 hours yesterday.
At least 11 hours yesterday.
So we'll see if we'll crash today.
We did a stress test with member goons.
um and we survived for three hours so we'll see uh okay the
only issue was okay before i yapp even more um i forgot to
pin something in chat something very important i'm like all
over the place here we go let me pin this real quick guys oh
oing me let me sorry that should be means that professional
streamer here join me
it's okay it's not two yet so technically the sponsor hasn't
started yet all right anyway so again huge shout out to
marvel right like i know the legal loopholes here the legal
loopholes and huge shout out to marvel rivals for sponsoring
today's stream in one minute for sponsoring the stream
that's gonna occur one minute.
So for those who don't know, Didi Dinosaur is back.
It's Didi's hearted older cousin, Devil Dinosaur.
So today is going to be an early access of Season 8 preview
for Double Dinosaur.
He's a tank.
He's a tank and it's actually really cool because he has a
tracking beam, which is nice.
He has a little, like, Emma, basically.
Yeah, I love the Didi or two electric boogaloo so yes we've
resurrected tank doki for 30 minutes because i'm not playing
tank when we do the little i don't maybe maybe sometimes we
like swap roles and stuff but i don't know a nice another
take for our tank mate let's if you want to support me
support rivals and the stream please feel free to click on
the link pinned um in chat or the panel in the description i
I guess that's called the panels are called descriptions for
Twitch.
But yeah, you can join me and play Marvel Rivals for free
right now.
All right, since now, now I can show you guys the screen
since it's two now.
But yes, it is Devil Dinosaur.
I believe 8.5 would be Cyclops because they showed Cyclops
here for a while.
But Moon Girl is here too.
She's not actually in the game.
Well, she's not playable.
You can hear her voice.
For those who don't know, Moon Girl is like the owner of
Devil Dinosaur for Marvel Rivals.
Sorry, I say for Marvel Rivals lore.
For Marvel lore.
But you can hear her voice and stuff when you're playing
Devil Dinosaur.
So I say thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, I need to get more cough.
I'll get more cough drops later.
Before the...
Oh, shit.
Yeah, you can see Cyclops are there.
But before the group events.
Yeah, there's...
Oh, for those who don't know, I think I like the Season's
Battler.
the season eight battle pass um they're friends not pen and
owner it's more than that anyway so this season this first
sorry season eight uh battle pass it's cowboy theme yippee
guy yeah so i thought that was pretty interesting anyway
wait is that dino oh my god wait i didn't even He's so
greedy.
More skins!
So he can make more merch of me!
More blind boxes, warriors!
Oh, Jeff's!
He looks like a little doggy with a little flappy ears too.
Oh my god, he looks like...
He looks like a little...
little puppy.
I...
I'll purchase it.
I'll purchase it with my fake early access money.
At least, yeah.
Rejoice, Hulk Mains.
You finally have a skin.
Anyway, 10 more skins for Jeff.
Oh, he does look like Clifford.
Well, you're right.
He does.
I know you said that.
All right, let's get Jeff the Dino.
And Luna.
Sorry.
20 skins for Luna.
And 10 more skins for Jeff.
And I guess we can throw in one for a Hulk.
God, you're so greedy, Hulk Mains.
Why are y'all so greedy?
Are you not satisfied with your one skin?
Anyway, there is the torch skin.
Oh, is this always a spray?
Oh, wait, what's this emo?
Behold me.
Oh, yeah.
That's torch.
Oh, is this like add-on the little iridescent thing?
You can barely see it when he's fucking burning you alive.
Gore was right.
Please, ma'am.
Just one skin.
They're so greedy.
I can't believe it.
You, what, you can't be patient.
You waited seven seasons for a skin.
You can't wait seven more.
Oh, yeah, he's unworthy.
Oh, shirtless.
There we go.
Equal rights.
I love rivals for being so, for preaching about equality.
Yeah, Hulk.
Their greed sickens me.
I always ask so much.
Oh yeah, it's a wooden hammer.
That's cool.
I like that.
I like that touch.
I like the little touches they put on the skin.
I'm glad.
I'm glad both the boys and the girls are treated equally
when it comes to skins.
Oh, and there's... Yee-ha!
Yee-ha!
Yes, give me.
There we go.
So there's the Mantis Cowboy skin.
I'll grab that mantis skin.
I mean, it's cute.
I like it.
I like the little...
What do they call it?
The little fluffy things dangling on the legs here.
The little ruffles down there.
It's pretty cute.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, she's dancing!
Another dancing mode at the boogie center.
The tassels.
Oh yeah.
The frills.
They're cute.
I like it.
They're really cute.
There's the look at her go look at her go and then oh This
is this is where Men and joyers can rise up this in season a
I keep saying this season, but season a Oh my god, what?
Okay, wait.
Let me let me analyze real quick This way whoa They gotta
play catch-up guys they gotta oh my god, I did not realize
that cape was hiding an entire army like that cape was
hiding some um some food under there what the your magneto's
leg day bro he's packing on both sides left right center up
down they hate yeah they hit a bakery Oh my god, might as
well just take off that helmet, Magneto.
It ain't not any much.
Alright, what is this?
You can actually make a full team of shirtless characters
now in Rivals.
We should do that.
I don't think they will agree.
Oh my god, what if...
Oh my god, Infinity Thing, the door is opening.
What if the thing was gay?
What if the thing was candy?
The bling looks like some jolly ratcher.
Oh my god.
Look at him.
He's like made of candy.
What if the thing was made of candy?
The everlasting gobstermin.
Oh, he has a green toe.
You can't oh my god, I can't unsee it now the one green toe
like why is it's like all pink and then the one green toe
Could be mold Oh, oh look at that now he can fly It's not
scary at all.
I love this.
Oh Wait, you could actually make wait you could do two two
two with all shirtless characters.
Okay, so be Captain America Captain America mag Uh, any of
the swimsuits for the support players, Punisher, and
Starlord.
That, you can literally make a full shirtless team.
Letting it all, letting it all out.
She's right.
Oh, Neymar doesn't count.
He's, he's like shirtless on, on business too.
He's shirtless on casual and business, so he doesn't count.
He never puts on a shirt on.
Shirtless, yeah.
No one, yeah, no one cares about them more.
What is this?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
You can beat up a lion.
Wait, did I miss out any?
Oh, there's the Cyclops.
Did I miss out any?
Oh, there it is.
I didn't see that.
All right.
Oh, there's Gamut Barrier Buster.
I might as well.
With my imaginary early access money.
Wait, what is this based off of?
But I gotta check on my time because I keep forgetting that
it's 30 minutes now instead of the usual hour, like in the
past.
Oh my god, look at him.
Go.
He's so fast.
Gambit never folds and he'll never, ever fold and then he'll
never fold and then Gambit never folds.
I hope we ban Gambit during the...
During the showcase.
I hope we ban Gambit.
it.
I don't want it.
I don't want to deal with it.
But that seems full.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I heard you get one clip people now.
I heard they did a huge buff on.
Oh, there she is.
Another cowboy.
Another cowgirl.
Yeehaw.
I would feel like it'll be super uncomfortable riding on a
robot horse compared to a regular horse.
There is no padding on that.
Oh my god, see?
You can add Rogue into the shirtless.
Well, technically not shirtless.
I mean, it counts.
I will say it counts.
You can add her to the shirtless team.
It definitely counts.
You're just saying that because you just want to play Rogue.
Oh, the dances are so cute, though.
Look at her go.
Ye-ha, girl.
Ye-ha!
What's some...
Some margaritas with that?
What is that drink that like older women drink in the
morning?
Sangria?
No, not Sangria.
Mimosas!
You want some mimosas, Rogue?
White claw?
Oh yeah.
Some...
Let's go!
She got a little too many mimosas.
A little too many mimosas.
She's ready to party!
Go, white girl, go!
Yeah, Sunday mimosas brunch, Monday mimosas brunch, Tuesday
mimosas brunch, it never ends!
Man, those are, I believe those are all the new skins.
Let me double check.
Oh, and then there's the new, oh wait, is that, who's that?
Who's, is that Moon Knight?
Who's the other guy?
all right now let's look at devil daughter he's so bulky i
was like i don't even know what his hit box is he seems like
two times the size of the other tanks like he's so goddamn
big i was looking at him um but here's his chrono armor yeah
he seems like the biggest tank he's so wide you know um it's
cute i love like the art i saw the illustrations of like
like Jeff is like be careful Jeff we're like uh where it's
like the dinosaur face behind Jeff's face and he's like he's
like watch out and it's shock bugle beast oh it's where he
has like he starts having mold growing on his legs all right
what's the MVP guys look it's DD dinosaur arr what's this
the wreck and run
all right let's see oh what's the emus oh she can sit down
he can sit down that okay i i guess i want to see him sit on
a front a small chair i think it would have been funnier if
he was like oh my god he's gonna sit down on a tiny ass
chair oh my i'm so looking for oh i feel like that was a
missed opportunity there all right here's the what was it
Where's the... Okay, here is... Where's the Lord?
Oh my god!
Did he just grow a beard?
Oh no, that's just like...
Oh my god.
Wait, that's hardcore.
Wait, I actually like that Lord icon.
That's pretty hardcore.
I mean, compared to the other...
It's like...
The puppy eyes versus the Lord icon.
Like, it's a huge difference, too.
Yeah, that Lord icon is pretty sick.
I like that.
He's like the devil and the angus.
All right, let's go actually check out.
Oh, wait, actually, wait, is there anything else?
Oh, oh, it's the...
What are the rewards?
All right, so the rewards are the...
Oh, the rewards are the banners and stuff.
So, wait, how about this one?
Is the same?
Oh, it's the same.
I didn't know if there was a skin for it or anything, but,
yeah, those are the rewards for the new event for Season 8.
And I think that's everything.
All right, now we go straight.
in i didn't read the instructions on how to play him so
we're gonna learn that live i just saw oh i just i only saw
like the trailer all right dd where is the beam there's the
beam there we go that's what i like to see yes what the oh
oh never mind it's just oh there is a oh there's a bar never
mind I can't spam that I can't just be like laser drag like
laser dino the entire time I do I have to melee I have to
melee no I want to be laser only dino it's all I wanted oh
my god yeah I can grab them too by the way I just want to
find my laser all right let's actually read Okay,
prehistoric, oh yeah, also the new team up is that the
Punisher can ride the Dino, but honestly I'm wondering like
how effective would that be?
Because you know how Groot also has, I think this is like
one thing where you're just like fucking around with your
buddy and It's where you fuck around with your, who cares,
it looks cool, Doki, who cares?
Let's fuck around with my friend.
So I'm just, like, wondering, like, I think it might work if
you just...
Oh, my melee.
Wait, who am I?
How am I using my melee?
Oh, it's my tail.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
It's so fast.
My tail breaks the speed of...
My tail breaks the speed of light and sound, apparently.
Like, I cannot even see it.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, I can't bite him.
Oh, I can't bite.
Wait, is it because I...
Is it because I'm a tank?
Can I bite others?
Can I chomp other people?
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Donald's trying to use the computer right now.
I know.
Oh, I have to bleed him first.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna eat him.
All right.
It's where's DD dinosaur.
There we go.
I'm yum yum.
I'm so hungry.
Oh my god Dino fight Dino fight Oh yeah, there's the shield
by the way I assume that's the shield Yeah, it is a shield.
It's a 350 HP Yeah, you can toss people off the map But then
obviously he has to be He can't carry them I assume But he
can't carry him I have like a one second or two second
leeway to it.
Yeah, that's the longest I can carry.
Primal rage.
Yeah, so there's the Moon Girl stuff.
So Moon Girl gives me a little...
Oh, it's 450.
Moon Girl gives me a little shield.
And then the multi-bite.
All right, let me read the other stuff.
I know.
Reading is so hard.
All right, so his alt is that he erupts in the Primal Fury.
gain a massive i mean it's little compared to him it could
be bigger it should just it should be the entire map it
barely how is this like you know how like in airport
regulations like the cage has to be like x um x to this
height or like length with this height or something so that
the dinosaur Or, sorry, the dog or cat would be comfortable.
This wouldn't even fit regulations.
You know how, like, bird cages has to be, like, the size of
a miniature room or something, or else it's considered pet
abuse or pet negligence?
Same with, like, same with, like, aquariums.
So I would say Moon Girl could give him a bigger shield.
Moon Girl could have given him a bit.
How would he be able to lie down in comfort, Moon Girl?
How could he?
He can barely lie down from tail to head, Moon Girl.
I'm not accusing Moon Girl of pedophies.
I'm just educating Moon Girl that Dinos needs to have a
bigger shield just for comfort-wise.
It has to fit his natural environment.
and his natural habitat.
He needs more space.
Does it move?
Yeah, it moves with me.
Alright, let's read the rest.
Alright, so he has massive movement and speed boosts while
unleashing earth-shattering storms that launch enemies and
apply lead.
Wait, the lead that deals continuous?
Wait, every time?
Takes reduced damage from critical hits.
Immune to launch up and knockback.
Oh, so he's like the thing.
So I'll let you guys see it.
He's like the thing.
So he doesn't have launch up or knockback.
Another display.
He doesn't get displaced.
And he also takes reduced damage.
You know, maybe, I mean, yeah, maybe put it.
I feel like if you like pump all your resources into the
Punisher, uh, Dino, uh, team up, then I, he could live.
He could survive.
I mean, he has bleed on all his abilities, which is, except
for shift.
Yeah, he has, oh, wait, no, all of, yeah.
Never mind.
He has bleed on all his abilities.
That seems very scary.
Amuse and Lila's sharing.
Less ultimate ability entry when damaging or healing.
Oh, okay.
You can't farm.
You can't farm all of him.
He's not an alt battery, like, group.
So, oh, and also the enemy team can't use him as an alt
battery as well.
bonus help when you flick.
Oh, you get bonus help when you flick bleeding?
That's so scary.
Okay, I think, move aside, tank pool.
We have a new tank coming in.
We have a new tank for Bandline.
Okay, let's see.
Dash and Pounce on your... What is F?
What is F?
Unleash just a flurry.
Converts the damage into bonus health.
Okay, so when I press F, I get more bonus health, too.
And then bleed and Oh, my laser!
Wait, I can knock down airborne targets.
I can actually, it's like, artillery fire.
I'm anti-air.
I don't think anybody can fly anyway.
This guy's anti-air, apparently.
And then, boom!
Yeah.
So there's no flying in this airspace.
And this one apparently slows.
And then...
That's so scary.
I feel like he does a lot of damage for...
Okay, show a laser range?
Sure.
It's not that far.
The laser range is not...
Um...
It's not that far.
Wait, okay, let me recharge my laser.
If I do that, do I just have infinite?
Yeah, so it's like here.
Oh, so then the flying guys can just move away.
I realized the Flyers can just take a step back because they
can fire their shots farther away.
Never mind.
Not as anti-air as I do.
I just jump, Joki.
Just jump and then you'll reach them.
Is there anything else new other than the team up?
Let's see.
I want to be the Punisher.
Come on, devil.
Let me on.
doesn't move.
Don't worry.
Okay, he doesn't move.
Oh, I can do smokes.
Oh, I can alt.
No, never mind.
I thought I could alt.
Imagine if you could alt on the Dino, because it will remind
me of another team up.
Like, I think, okay, I think if he could alt, it would have
been absolutely broken.
I will say that.
Let me on.
All right.
Yeah, it would have been so busted.
I wonder if...
Okay, can I...
How about me as a Dino?
Alright, get on me.
Get on me.
Come on.
Get on the Dino.
Get on...
Okay, there you go.
Okay, yeah.
I can...
I can do the beam while he shoots.
So I can slow people down.
Can Dino up with the Punisher on him?
I'm pretty sure I can.
Yeah.
So that's scary, actually.
A lot of people will play Dino Punisher.
Never mind.
This is actually scary.
Unless you're able to gun him down.
A thousand three hundred?
I just got to a thousand three hundred with bonus health.
Holy shit.
He's built like a fucking tank.
Just a mobile.
Yeah, it's a mobile Punisher turret.
Yeah.
I got to a thousand five hundred HP.
Because he is a dad.
The literal tank.
And the fact that he applies bleed on all his attacks.
Can I bite people while I can?
I wonder.
You know what I wonder?
I wonder if I can shift and when I have him in my jaw, if
the Punisher can shoot him while I have him on my jaw.
I'm going to ask that during the showcase.
Because I'm curious.
Because I feel like when you have him in the jaw and it's
like the Elsa ult.
Where they're in the giant monster ult.
And then you can shoot them while they're in it.
I feel like you can, I feel like maybe if I press shift, if
I grab him up, and then the Punisher can just headshot his
head while I have him in my jaws.
Yeah, I can all with the Punisher on.
Yeah, I can see.
And I can even give us a shield.
Oh, my God.
I can give us a shield with an all.
So the Punisher can have free rate.
Never mind.
You know, I said that I was like, who's going to use this in
an actual fight, like in an actual rank?
I think, never mind.
Now that I might be pretty strong.
Never mind.
I think he might be actually pretty strong as a Punisher
Tano duo.
It's just more so you have to have supports that will not...
Like, it's just literally babysitting these two for the rest
of the game.
I feel like...
Oh, okay.
But who uses the Groot Rocket team?
I don't think I've ever got on a Groot's back before.
Because the Groot is always like, let's go die.
And I'm like, let me stand 70 miles away from you.
Like, I do.
Oh, okay.
I mean, everybody uses that team up, though.
You're right.
You're so right, guys.
I never trust my Groot enough.
It saved my life once.
Okay, but how many attempts did it take to get you that one
moment?
how many attempts did it take for that one moment where he
saved your life
one save out of how many wait where's the i want to read the
what was this one okay unleash let's see unleash it doesn't
okay it slows bleed and slow it stops that launch his enemy
okay i just it launch and it slows too so it's like a
permanent slow uh it counts as what it's we it's a shared
healing pool basically uh dash like not like it's like uh
basically they both the damage will be shared between the
two so they gain damage reduction uh devil dinosaur absorbs
the portion of all damage inflicted on the punisher and
shares some of his healing receive so yeah so I think it's
the same when you're on Punisher.
They just, they don't care how often it works.
They just, they just want to feel safe.
Dash and pound, activate a heart share.
Oh, wait, enemies caught within are slowed?
Oh my God, she just, he just slows everything.
Wait, the shield even slowed.
Wait, the shield with the all would go fucking crazy.
Because then everybody would be like slowed oh my god i
don't want to i'm scared i'm i'm so scared if i see this
when i see the dino in game i fear i think dino might be an
instaband of that because he does slow on everything he
slows on he slows on his beam he slows on his shield he
slows on his ult and he bites people He carries people away
with his shift.
Oh my god.
Imagine the speed.
Oh my.
Gab it all with.
Okay.
Gab it all with DD Dinosaur.
What does our double dinosaur will go so hard.
Was that all the changes?
What are changes do they do?
Can't wait to chomp chomp.
Is there any other changes, guys?
Any other big changes?
Oh yeah.
I had Magneto bubble.
Just small nursing bubble.
All right, who got nerfed and who got buffed?
Oh, the rank reward?
Yeah, I can show you.
Is that...
It's almost time for the showcase anyway.
There you go.
No, not that.
It's been a while since I looked at it.
All right, customize.
There you go.
Is that a nuclear bomb?
Wait, is that a...
Yeah.
Yes, okay, I think what the fuck is that kind of look?
Okay, so the top 500 reward is it's a nuclear bomb.
Oh, it's a volcano.
I don't know, it looks pretty bomb-like.
I don't know, it looks like a mushroom cloud.
Is it, is it, okay, is it a nuclear volcano?
Can't tell.
I can't tell because there's a fucking cloud around the
volcano.
Okay, it's a nuke on a volcano.
Don't pull the damage.
Oh, is that building?
That's a building?
Why is this so volcano mushroom-like?
Alright, okay, apparently it's a building.
Never mind.
I was like, oh my god.
Why?
The reward is a nuke?
Damn.
Oh, and then there's Cyclops for those who want to see what
he looks like.
Oh, it's from future.
Oh, it's a future.
I guess in the future, all buildings just look like
volcanoes and bombs.
I guess that's what the future is like in New York City.
All buildings shall now look like bombs or volcanoes.
Just how it is.
all right let's see let me check if there's anything we
should be oh yeah we're we should we should be regrouping in
now i guess where where's the server where is the server
where is the server there you go my rival's preview uh oh
not last i'm gonna def in while i join it and i'm gonna
While I set up, I'll show you, I'll just AFK as DD dinosaur.
Sorry, double dinosaur.
I'm so used to saying DD dinosaur.
Yeah, it just seems really fun to play, though.
It seems real, it says four star, but he seems a lot.
He seems pretty easy.
I guess it's the combos.
I think if you know the combos, then bomb, chomp, no!
Oh my god, his face when he gets chomp, though.
I think when pros slash high-ranked players figure out the
combos on Devil Dancer, it's going to be really scary.
Because already he seems really scary.
Yes, they say he's streamed up.
I feel like he's a 2-star.
Honestly, not a 3-star.
Oh, wait.
Mattis gives speed boost?
I did not see that.
Martial Arts sharpens your mind.
Is it...
Is it from his...
Is it that?
I mean, she does sort of feel fast.
Is it from the Inspire?
Is she faster?
Oh my god, yee-ha.
Our enemies are here.
Oh, is there Nate?
I didn't look at the store.
I forgot about the store.
Let me look at the store real quick.
Oh, yeah, there's the King Deadpool.
King Pula.
Oh, yeah, this one.
I saw that one.
zombies but he's always naked oh my god he's fully naked i
was like what are you guys talking about he's he's always
naked oh it's speed instead of he's fully naked adam now has
a naked friend
oh my god i was like what are you talking about he's always
naked guys difference.
All right, let's be a Mechadano.
All right, let me put on Mechadano.
And then there's King Pooh.
I told you, you can make a full team of naked characters.
Both sides.
There's enough for both teams to have a naked roster.
Where's the OP Mechadano?
know oh yeah i saw the fruity pebbles thing i did he has a
little green toe too but i want to which one was all the
okay i equipped the mantis and luffy jeff i guess that's it
oh and then adam if i get to play adam today it has to be oh
i don't have to battle pass forgot but let's if you're
enjoying Um, you want to support Rivals and today's stream?
Make sure to click on the link pinned in the chat or in the
panel below.
You should again too, Marble Rivals, for sponsoring today's
stream and allowing me to have early access to Dino
Dinosaur.
Or Devil Dinosaur.
All right, let's see.
I need to...
Oh, what is his promise?
Yeah, no problem.
Let me get it for you.
Buh-buh-buh-buh.
Where is he?
No, that's a strategist.
Where's Mecha Dino?
Oh, my God.
I keep thinking.
I thought he was red for a sec.
I keep forgetting he's gray now.
I think it's this, right?
Like, quad.
I think his lord icon goes really hard compared to, like,
the other lords.
Like, I mean, it takes a, like, majority of the screen.
Like, it takes a majority of the banner, too, which is nice.
Legendary devil dinosaur.
Dino dinosaur.
All right, let me set up the audio stuff real quick, guys.
while i do that you guys can look at him just look at him
okay what is uh marvel davis preview wait what is the server
called marvel rival's preview oh i was right all right by
the way after the sponsor we're gonna keep playing more
marvel rivals because i have to do the other marvel rival
sponsor on the twitch board Never-ending Marvel, right?
I don't- I won't be playing on my main because, like, I
don't want to sweat too hard today.
So, I'll be playing on an alt account.
I'll be playing on the- my tank alt account, but I won't be
playing tank.
Tank Doki has been resurrected only for today.
I don't even- for only today in the practice range.
Alright, there it is.
What a voice channel, aren't we?
Voice A.
Okay.
Oh my god, there's like 20 100 voice a voice a bcs 245 okay
which is my voice a okay it's not this voice a it's not oh
it's this voice a all right let me set this up they're all
talking now but they all got off of headphone deafened mode
all right for those who don't know i'm at least also here
and on my team Oh.
Chase three the bald.
Yeah.
Whips want to be the test.
Can we can you ride Jeff with the emote and also have
Punisher riding Devil Dino?
Yeah.
All right.
We had to test out the mute button to make sure it works.
Look at him little stompies.
But do you guys know if you can like when you when the If
the Devil Dinosaur charms on someone, can the Punisher shoot
them in his mouth?
You guys know if that works?
Surely, right?
Yeah, you could.
If the Devil Dinosaur has someone in his mouth, can the
Punisher just headshot the person in the mouth?
Because I feel like that'd be broken.
Maybe.
I feel like you could.
I mean, yeah, because that's, yeah.
So, okay, so.
All right, so, yeah.
Got to run the Dinosaur Shotgun Punisher.
Asked to happen.
Oh, absolutely.
I'm going, whoever's playing Dino, bro, I'm sorry, but I'm
riding you.
Please.
I'm asking the important questions here.
Whips, please get this guy.
Who is this guy?
Oh, yeah, the sound guy.
If you're listening, type to me in Discord for balancing.
I need a no for balancing.
I'm planting the seeds.
Yeah, I'm planting the seeds.
seeds for them to destroy the enemy team i think we'll get
destroyed okay maybe 50 50 i don't know i don't it could be
50 50.
the other team might have more try hearts very beautiful
rogue skin i will be getting that i will be making rogue in
season eight yep i have officially decided i might not be
mating her but i will be definitely getting that skin
everyone's talking I'm gonna grab that hook is sick too do
you see that I might have yeah I might have on the on the
Marvel algorithm maybe stream a little too long right now
where the thing just hides behind the corner and he's
sitting down waiting for a black panther to come by I have
seen those but now it's going to be the him ascending
instead I'm getting out of this guy no get out I don't care
I need my bro.
Yeah, secure top 500.
Hello.
Hey, what's up?
What's up?
Are you doing?
Yo.
Nice to meet you guys.
I'm Amma.
Hello.
Nice to meet you.
Very nice to meet you.
Hello.
Dude, this character's sick.
I'm so excited.
Same.
Drew.
I can't wait.
Okay, I think we all agree.
Jay plays the dinosaur last.
Everyone else gets a turn and then Jay can play Dido.
me out we play loki as well and we have two dinos all at the
same time that sounds insane i tried it out in the in the uh
the like in the customs and i was like this is gonna be
disgusting i'm down wait if you have two devil dinosaurs and
you inflict the bleed and i inflict the bleed is that two
bleeds i think so i think for as long as like loki's ulting
also if you're rogue and you copy him you get like 830 hp as
rogue which is crazy so rogue old team's gonna be nasty did
you see how much hp he has it's like i think it was 12 where
did it start with 1225 or so yeah i think i got to like 1300
with like the bleed stacks like in his old which is so nasty
oh yeah sorry about yeah i think my chest that i got to 1500
at one point oh god yeah i think imagine that double yeah i
was like that's crazy wait what do you mean by loki what
does he do uh if loki copies and also ults as dino oh he
gets double his hp or something uh i think he gets all the
stacks too i think so you can have like two dino's yeah i
love it hey hey we'll never see it coming jay you're not
making fun of my hair bro there's no there's no way i think
it's crazy the mouse slows you can have on double dinosaur
with all the stuff he can do I think like each ability
almost has a slow I'm really trying to I feel like I don't
I'm curious how the shield's gonna get used feels very
situational bro you can block any old any old mag wait
really oh and it's a movable shield too so the mag has to
like go up close to throw the rock
whips you just got that ready to go for my stream like
that's just ready to go Whips just showed a clip of you
being bald on my stream.
He has that, I think, on his desktop.
Audio balancing.
That's crazy.
Craigie, Jay up, and then I'm down.
Whips, can you send that over to me, please?
No, no, you're good, bro.
You're good.
What are you going to do with that photo?
It's not a photo.
It ain't a photo.
It was a video, bro.
It was a video of you bending over.
That sounded insane.
But like, whoa, whoa.
What?
What is the context, Jay?
what was the context i'm glad that you didn't come to my
birthday party you didn't invite me how am i supposed to go
if you don't invite me would you have god if you invited you
i have lasses i have cloaks not yours did you not facetime
me once no it was on dennis's phone wasn't it yeah hey bro
you see look you're just exposing yourself as a fake friend
look at that old friend i mean i thought you had my number
just get my number i hate you that's wild that's okay i wish
you were the there man when was it last saturday oh shit
this like just happened wow okay wait did you not know when
his birthday is i didn't no that's that's just another
that's rough that's rough jay that's how did you turn how
did you turn jay i i turned 32 hey oh getting up there damn
like i know tim's birthday on the top of my like wait do you
know how tim is you had to just look that up no i like i i'm
just a guy known you for eight years bro i'm good friends
with you yeah how old is tim how old is tim tim didn't know
how old you were i i you go i see that you googled it on
your stream bro my birthday's november 9th bro who snitched
that's crazy wait i'm not the youngest one here though right
not the stream sniping last you want to go first stream
sniping already hell yeah brother i think i'm gonna play
does anyone know which supports the got buffed i didn't read
all the patch notes loki is healing loki got buffed oh
rocket got buffed yeah what did they buff for rocket white
fox is all right yeah his left pick out one more damage his
right click got two more ammo capacity and his ulti charges
faster okay yeah yeah all right let's go then what was that
wait what did they buff on white fox then uh it kind of
changed it now in her ulti heals for more now and her just
being around her heals for more oh okay so she just does
more healing all right her left click like her auto attack
doesn't heal as much in her ult oh okay it's just like her
non-alp farm all right thank you thank you for letting me
copy her homework i got buffed i was like i was too busy on
the dino i didn't look at the other stuff tell me dad how
big you are oh i feel like we'd actually like hard pocketed
die now because you're gonna take so much damage you might
need a jeff we might need a jeff for the speed boost oh
that's true that's true and then rocket can win at me all
right are you are you okay are you okay oh a donna versus
donna we're not gonna let you die don't worry yeah it's like
a joke oh wait they're on the right there's a sound they're
going and watch out Get me on.
Get me on.
Go.
It's a dino fight.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm helping.
I'm helping.
I need up.
I got you.
Dino fight.
Wait, someone gets the outfit.
this.
I shot him.
Oh, yo, go here, go here, go here.
Oh, my God.
They TP'd.
Oh, the Dino's here.
Oh, my God.
Jesus Christ.
Wait.
Oh, I got knocked off.
Oh, God.
It's fine.
We're winning.
It's so winnable.
Some of you may die, but it's a sacrifice.
Hey, why is there a strange here?
I got him.
Don't worry.
Oh!
Where I got you?
This has no Dino!
Punisher has no Dino!
Kill him!
Come here!
I got you!
Let's go, let's go!
Kill him he has no horse, he has no horse!
Oh no!
No!
We don't have a horse, oh wait, iron fist is low!
And iron fist is one.
He's one, he's one.
Nice, nice!
Okay, wait, we're gonna have ult with Loki and Dino.
Can we try it?
Oh, that's gonna be awesome.
Yes, yes, yes!
Yeah, yeah, muy awesome!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, the dino is punishers-less.
He doesn't have a knife.
I have my knife back.
I got my old.
Let me know when you have it.
You're only 90.
Oh, no.
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
I'm out.
I'm scared.
Oh, no.
Oh, goodbye.
Don't worry.
I'll take you home.
Oh my god.
I'm bringing the pun- I'm bringing the Iron Fist with us
too, by the way.
So, good luck, guys.
Let's kill him.
Get him.
Kill him.
There's a dinosaur in his phone.
Watch out.
Oh, he got it.
Are we ready?
I have Dino.
Yeah, let's do it.
I got it.
He doesn't.
He has a Punisher.
She has a Punisher.
Just go in.
Oh my gosh.
It's a Dino fight.
Oh, I don't know what's going on.
I don't know.
Oh, no, it's horrible.
Oh, wait.
You got me instead.
I'm running.
Goodbye.
You know, I think a lot of...
running triple they're running they're on triple support
solo take have they no shame i know wait how do i how do i
turn on confirm for loki um uh it's in it's in the heroes
you gotta look at the heroes like you have to change hero
and then go to loki right oh yes yes yes yes oh ow ow there
yeah all right well i'm gonna use my old around this corner
there's an iron fist above us yep i'm there is an iron fist
right behind us by the way cause we're going he got this
craig i believe oh yeah no we got him we got oh no he's gone
He's gone.
It's okay.
We got the shark though.
Dude, the little Jeff dinosaur is so funny.
It is so cute.
Oh,
Loki on me in the back.
Oh, no, I don't like that.
Yo, I'm kind of...
Oh, son of a god.
Oh, no!
I don't like this guy.
Oh, here.
Where do we go?
We shall go.
It's okay.
We should live this.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, they're low, they're low.
Yeah, they're low.
Punisher's low too.
Punisher's one.
Keep going.
We're not done yet.
I'm coming inside.
I need help.
Oh, yeah.
Fuck.
I know some dragoons have access to the mod channel.
So can someone DM the mods to get on right now?
Nice.
Can someone DM?
I know some of the dragoons are friends with the mods.
Can someone DM the mods to get on?
I can't do it because I'm in the game.
I can't change right now.
I'm the dinosaur?
Oh my god.
I think I'm dead.
I got rings there.
I got rings.
Oh, I don't think we're living.
I don't think we're alive.
The title is slowing us.
I thought I could turn it around.
Oh, move back.
Oh god.
Run, Doki, run.
I am not gonna live.
I don't have my dash.
Alright, I died.
I can't do it.
Good, good, good.
Yeah, I believe.
We'll just strike.
Um, wait, I shall message one of my ad cards right now.
This time.
Yeah, what the?
Yeah, there's a there's a punch man back here.
Yeah.
All right.
I'll be choosing my dinosaur.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, we're going up, Jay.
All right, I messaged my admin mine.
We're going for the dinosaur.
Oh, he got deleted.
No!
I'm being taken away.
I'm gone.
Oh my god.
Yeah, are you with me?
He's not gonna make it.
Yeah, I'm with you.
Oh, damn.
I'm actually like the higher level mods.
We're taking away.
Oh, this is so stressful.
Oh, everybody's dying.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna tell my, I need more mods.
I'm telling him right now.
Punchy boy is so annoying.
Big red.
Yeah, I like that.
All right.
Okay, when we come back.
We have both.
Oh, we got the double dynamo.
We got the double dynamo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They won't expect it.
I'm coming back now.
Should I call this a double D, the double D, bro?
Should I get off just to make sure you can't get them?
I have it on confirm now.
I got it.
I got it now.
All right.
You ready?
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
All right, here we go.
Double dynamo, double dynamo!
Oh my god.
Wait, are we?
I'm gonna get away from that.
Guys, are we losing?
Yeah, we might be losing.
What happened?
Oh, the dino's not working!
The double dino's not the play, guys!
What happened?
No, we're killing him!
We're killing him!
He's won!
Oh, he's shielded!
He's shielded!
Where'd the other dino go?
What happened?
I just melted.
He might have died.
We might need...
A trip support.
Maybe to heal through it.
I might need...
My oldest guy.
Oh, I'm going to send it to Emo only mode.
I don't know where my other...
I don't know where my head mod is.
Emo.
Only.
Wait, I'll do sub only, actually.
I like that.
It's pretty big old.
I'll do sub only.
Oh, it's actually really good.
Really good.
Yo, I got one.
I got one.
Chop, chop, chop, chop, chop.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
You got that?
Oh, I'm stuck.
Oh, we got a touch.
We got a touch.
I gotta go.
I gotta go for it.
That's a beautiful jump.
Beautiful jump.
Go for it.
I'm in.
I touch.
I got TP coming.
All right.
There we go.
That should work.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, I feel bad because I've just been trying to deal with
this.
I'm through it.
And I'm dead.
Oh, my God.
No.
Keep stalling.
I'm here.
I think they bought this game very busy.
My game crashed.
Oh, that's why they won.
No, we'll chop it out.
That's how it out of that.
Okay.
All right.
Um, start, start.
Look, we were, look, we were winning until trip was support.
I will say that.
Yeah, trip support.
We rolled in the first point and the trip came out and it's
a lot harder.
It's a lot harder.
Were they running trip?
Yeah, they were.
They were in trip at the moment we got first win.
that's what happened all right we time for me to ride tim
good comms good comms thank you yeah let's go baby come on
give me a there bro give me a there
oh that was awkward sorry guys i didn't i think that was the
spam that are you you that they were talking about me me i'm
back i'm back i think that's what they were i remember the
last that marvel ride was termed they were saying that
people were getting spanned by stuff i think oh yeah we're
having i know ghosts yeah i'm asking if we can get more any
mods because a lot of our mods are eu a lot of our mods are
eu so uh is very good at riding so they might not be on
right now that's why genuinely but my head mod is this could
be taken out of context But we have to keep the context in
mind here.
We're talking about as Punisher on dinosaurs.
That's what we're talking about.
Yeah.
That's one of the things we're talking about.
Do we want to do Loki again or nah?
It's up to you guys.
Is that like whatever you feel like?
I'm saying white foxes.
There's a bug.
I suppose you know Gambit.
I do know Gambit.
Let's do Gambit.
Oh, no.
I don't have my sexy skin.
Oh, there we are.
There we are.
All right, here we go.
God, this is nice.
Imagine there's a B-hop.
Oh, B-hop on Dino would be crazy.
Unless I get back a...
Sorry, sorry for the spaz, guys.
I'm sorry.
But tandem seats on the Dino.
I mean, my favorite thing is when you're moving, you see
Punisher's legs just move over.
You move with the angle that he's looking.
It's pretty good.
This is where we hold them.
The gambit?
We won't get first point.
We got this.
That was just practice that last time.
Alright, get him, Greggy.
Oh no, they die.
I'm only hearing dinks right now.
Bro, he's aura farm walking.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Get back on.
Don't worry, you're still healthy.
We got you.
We're really healthy.
Hurry, I'm gonna hit the shotgun now.
Nice, nice.
Nice shotgun.
Yo, I'm sucking the Dyno.
Oh, I'm scared.
Give it back in there.整corrhine.
We're still healthy.
We're not done yet.
Okay, nice, nice.
Oh, I'm coming.
I got there, Dyno!
I love, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm coming back.
Spider-Man dead.
That's good enough.
He's taking me.
Oh, I'm off.
I'm off.
I got him now.
Bro, we got him.
We got him, we got him, we got him!
Nice, nice!
No!
I'm dead!
It's going through Dino is dead too though!
Oh my god, you're taking so much damage.
I know, I know, I know.
Oh my god.
Oh, witch!
I'm gonna just try and keep you alive, Sims!
It's okay!
I know I'm dead!
Okay, we're in the shark belly, it's no longer okay.
i died me too can we uh can we tp i have all i don't know
moxie oh uh there's no time yeah yeah oh yeah we don't have
time yeah i i would have just locked this down sorry you
need to stop that vehicle you know what where's our dinosaur
i i always should have got kidnapped they got me back here i
got abducted oh my god they took me away bro
Oh, apologies.
We can gambit quantum assaults here.
I like that.
Yep.
All right, here we go.
I'm ready.
Oh, my God.
I got ult, too.
We can still go.
Yeah, still wait.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
We don't have ult.
I got, I got, I got laser beam to blast out of the air,
dude.
That was shit.
Oh my God, I got deleted.
I got deleted.
Oh, no.
They're dino ulting.
I grabbed him in it.
Wait, why?
Oh, wait, you got stun there.
No, I died.
Oh, no.
Oh, wait, am I... Wait, I'm lagging here.
There was lag.
Oh, no.
Oh, yeah.
That's scary.
Give me on it, Tim.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we're gonna ult in.
Is that there?
Okay, you guys ready?
Oh, I'm lagging so high.
Wait for... Wait for my ship, Craigie.
Then we go.
There we go.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I'm ready.
Oh my god.
There's so much damage.
A lot going on.
A lot happening.
Guys, I'm like so hard, Jaguars.
I'm just, let me shoot at a general direction and hope for
the best.
Let's hope for the best.
Oh, everything wrong can go wrong.
Cranky, what's the cooldown on you riding me?
Stop.
A couple of seconds, Tim.
A couple of seconds.
Oh, I might have to, I need to die so I can play where I
could.
I don't, I don't even.
I got him.
I'll punch him.
Oh, my God.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
I can at least try to do this on Raccoon.
I didn't know what my frames are.
Thank you.
I didn't know what is the network status.
Where am I at?
Oh my God.
That dinosaur shield saved them.
There's definitely a way to B hop on this dinosaur.
Now I'm okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh, the moment I want to see what my ping is, it fucking
resets itself.
But until then.
Oh, I got you, Jay.
Like 10 or 12 seconds.
Who are you fighting?
You're demons?
I'm being taken away.
There was a star lord and I am.
Oh, okay.
Well, there was a star lord here he is now.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Everything is so fine.
Okay.
He has a shield on.
That shield is actually so broken.
Oh my god.
Genius.
Wait, that shield is so broken.
He puts the shield while he grabs you so you can't get
healed.
I'm here, Craigie.
Thank you.
Oh, good board.
There is a rat.
There's a spot on me.
You got you got you got you.
There was a spot on me.
I do have old.
We can still hold this with our old.
Yeah.
I have to use gambit first.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll use gambit.
Oh, nice.
Got mine.
Guys, what?
I'm going down.
Oh, you are deep in there.
I'm getting eaten.
I'm sorry.
Oh, my do it.
Do it.
If you die here, I have res.
Oh, I know.
I'm coming.
You're rising.
You're right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just got in time.
I got their dino.
Oh, hello.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
I don't know what's going on.
I don't know either.
Sorry, we live.
I gotta kill.
I gotta kill somehow.
We fucking live.
No.
I'm gonna go back to spawn and rethink my actions.
Oh, careful.
Oh, okay.
Well, we don't have.
Back up, back up, back up, back up.
This might be where our data dies.
He took me away.
He took me to him.
I have my ult if we can somehow hold this.
Yo, last week in combo and this could be kind of wild.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm stuck in Narnia, but I will be there.
No, no, no.
This should be perfect.
We can still recontest, I believe.
Yeah, you'll hit him.
You'll hit him with the back door.
They're not even gonna see it coming.
The Spider-Man has us.
Okay, you ready?
Yeah, yeah, I'm coming.
I'm going.
I'm going now.
He might eat you.
Moxie swallowed me, bro.
Me too.
He swallowed two of us.
Wait, that's smart.
The jetball is like a counter to the to the dono.
Yeah, bro, when you guys are riding each other, you can't
let someone else swallow.
Oh, no.
bro let's get this raccoon yes i'm scared bro why is this
moving i'm on it yeah yeah yeah yeah things are gonna be
different this time earnings will be fine i'll slightly deep
this is winnable this is winnable very throw on this bridge
i'm gonna throw them off the map yeah this is it this is
where you shine there is a dino behind us by the Oh, yeah.
Left side, left side.
Yeah.
No!
Oh, man.
I saw the big ass plank.
I gotta be honest, bro.
I must have terrible aim, bro.
I don't know.
I thought I was hitting him there.
That was crazy.
No, that can't be your ace, Tim.
Your ace.
You can't have terrible aim of your ace.
Okay, okay.
Right, right, right.
It was the range.
Yeah, yeah.
It's the range.
He was just like one centimeter away.
My bad, my bad.
I don't know.
Wait, I can go back on though.
there's a dino flank in there oh okay i'm ready i'm gonna go
in with mine oh my god oh my god that's a lot of damage i'm
just gonna play this this corner okay there's a spider-man
on us do you hear him nice we could push probably yo no i
tried to throw him off
I'll live, I have up.
I'm so dead.
Here we go.
I'm scared, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
No, you got it, you got it.
Don't be scared.
This guy is a unique.
Oh, goodbye.
What is happening?
Um, you might be dead.
We might be dead.
Oh, God.
Everything that could go wrong might have gone wrong.
I don't have to.
Oh, Craig, you robbed me one last time.
What a final sentence.
You're dying words.
I think we're fine to get off subman.
People can be freed now.
10 to 9.
Nice.
You're pretty good, Tim.
Thanks, bro.
Yeah.
I grabbed flats out of here and I'll take that as a moral
victory, bro.
I love that.
Can you not throw the other dino?
All right, we're modding new people.
I am getting names right now for new mods.
them make sense what happens if you jumped off the map with
him all right i'm grabbing we're getting the na mods in you
blow up so fast okay so twitch was to eat for some reason so
i'm gonna twitch had the eu mods only modded and not the na
mods i thought i had everybody modded i don't know if i had
i don't because like youtube we have na mods but like uh i
don't know if i was given the names for the twitch because i
don't stream to on twitch as often So, um, so I think like,
they forgot my head mod forgot to give me the names for the
enemy mods.
Wolverine, bro.
Oh, you're the mantis.
They were to read it.
Oh my.
A lot of stories.
But I'm just waiting for the names right now.
Oh, I, what are the...
You want to tag with the last show I mean to?
Either or.
I'm indifferent.
I mean, I can ride craggy.
I can tank.
Yeah, I can do.
I can do whatever you guys want.
Yes, you can.
Wait, can the enemy mods talk to me.
The head mod is AFK.
I can like, what am I?
The moment I got out of the game!
Get the NA mods type in chat right now and I can mod you!
Right now before the game starts!
Please!
Okay, I can't even...
Oh, here, go ahead.
I was like, give me the name now.
This is the only time slot I can do it.
It's a victory!
This is a, this is, we figured it out.
This is where...
This is the one.
Is that speed boost like noticeable?
I don't know.
Let's find out now.
Oh my god, you guys take so much damage.
Yeah, oh.
I understand why we went triple.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's GG.
It's GG.
It's over.
Oh, it's over for you guys.
Guys, guys, you're so low.
You're so low.
And then we got it.
We got it.
We're so back.
There's a guy up here.
There's a guy up here on the high ground.
Oh.
He's weak.
I'm punching him.
Is he weak?
Yeah, he is.
But I'm back.
I'm gonna give you a scream.
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
You're solo.
I'm here.
Get me in there.
I got your dinosaurs.
I'm jumping.
Wait, they're solo.
They're solo.
Nice.
Job's not done.
Oh, we're getting them.
There we go.
Damien.
Give me in there, baby.
Well, maybe come on.
Come on.
Swinging my tail.
Go faster, Dad.
Go again.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, get him, get him.
Yeah, I'm giving you guys food, Steve.
Hey, there's a wall, there's a wall, there's a wall, there's
a wall.
Don't worry.
You have so much.
Oh, you have no more speed.
I'm just giving you heals now.
Yeah, I almost got my ulti, dude.
Oh, look out, dude.
No, don't worry.
I've blown him.
Oh.
yo i'm ready are we ready are we ready no i might be able to
steal them all nice nice you have so much speed you have so
much speed oh huge oh my god someone's on our cart someone's
on our cart where is he he like left oh i hit him with the
smoke oh oh my god why were you all the way there that's my
timmy over extended I went a little D, but I have all here.
We can use it.
Yeah, I can use it.
All right.
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I slept somebody.
Oh, whoa.
I ulted as well.
Oh, they, they, everyone's popping ults here.
Right, if you haven't popped ult yet, pop it now.
He's one of you.
He's going to be swallowed.
I just continually get swallowed.
Things you've never said.
Oh, God.
Oh, I'm no.
Okay, we might be dead here.
Oh, this might be bad.
Or it might be good.
Oh, we're good.
We're good, I think.
Yeah, yeah, we're good, we're good.
I'm trying to get you guys as much use.
All right, now I go.
I'm going for the dino.
Go for the dino.
What the dino is low?
He's blinded.
Nice, nice, nice.
We got punishing?
No.
Oh, I need help.
Yeah, yeah, we got two.
We got two.
Wolf is low.
Oh, never mind.
Wolf's getting healed.
I thought I killed him.
Scoopy.
Go.
Nice.
Oh, huge slam.
Yeah.
They'll pass it.
I might go crazy.
Nice.
Yo, thing is actually really good into this because I'm
punching pun, pun and dino at the same time.
Nice.
Oh, wait, that's true.
Riding together.
You get like the doubles.
I love it.
Wait, can can Rockets still ride Grood because that's so
funny actually?
I've got all of you.
I think so.
I never took it off.
Let's go.
We're going in.
We got that.
Oh, that's the other one.
I love it!
In the back!
I'm going in!
Hey, he's fucking going?
We're eating the thing!
Um, guys, there is a...
There is a Deadpool.
He's an ultim Deadpool.
He's low, though.
Oh!
Matt, this is so strong.
Guys, he's so...
Oh, guys!
He's so...
Just jumping around!
I can't...
I can't kill him.
I can't kill this.
He's still so low!
You...
Oh, wait!
He died!
He see 90!
He see 90 because he took a picture!
We got him!
I like that It was an aura all
Don't worry Don't worry you baited him into C90 Yeah with
that all You saw he took a picture He couldn't believe it
Guys can you swap so I can have Okay wait a minute No she
can't say that because she played When they played triple
support This is our This is our plus one It's our turn.
I know you're almost dead, but let me ride you.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
Daddy, daddy, upies, upies.
I'm not...
I'm not guru.
He goes, how about guru not play thing or Emma?
He goes, yeah, right, buddy.
I got a thing, I got a thing.
I can ult this.
Let's go.
Give you speed.
Nice.
Go, go, go.
I'm giving you so much speed.
While I have...
I want to ult as well.
They're on.
Oh my god.
I have packet loss.
I can't shoot Deadpool right now.
No!
Find your packets.
Find them.
He's like jumping all over.
It's not even like regular lag.
I just have packet loss for some reason.
Dude, did that.
Let's just take him back.
and jump off the map and say, yo, I think he just took a
picture and fell off the map.
Classic.
Oh my gosh, 50% packet loss.
Is anyone else having packet loss?
It's just me.
No, I did crash, but I'm not having packet loss.
That's so weird.
We had never had packet loss before.
Oh, big grab there.
Wow.
Oh yeah, you see that?
That was sick.
All right, I'm going insane here.
I'm going crazy.
It's nice, nice.
We love it.
We love crazy.
I've got the shot.
Yeah, I'm jumping.
I'm jumping in.
We're alting.
That's their alting.
We have nothing for that.
I'm dead.
That's who?
Oh.
We're going to get let down there.
I died.
Don't worry.
We got a lot.
We got a lot of ults here.
Oh, they're trips up.
Again.
Shameless.
I didn't realize they were doing it again.
At least we're not running triple support.
That's right.
I mean, unless...
It would be a shame if something does that up.
Oh no!
Oh my god.
I can't find him.
Oh no!
We gotta reset.
No!
swallow me one more time i think he's gonna swallow it is oh
you got both of you wait you guys might die though you have
no no we're not there we're not there to save you we're
staggering we're staggering high caliber so there's no more
damage boost right it's just speed oh oh he can Oh, nice.
We got two.
There now.
There's still damage boost.
Oh, there's still some, but they added speed.
But you can't be up with the dinosaur though.
Ooh, that's a good tech to know.
Nice, nice, nice.
There we go.
Um, shoot.
Oh, no.
Oh, you won!
Oh, never mind.
It's getting healed.
Someone's getting healed here.
We're so close to your old.
he was all right I'll go in with my okay it's okay we win
this we win this yeah yeah we got a lot of bolts now we got
a lot of bolts yeah and then we we should just use their
cloak like if they use another support yeah yeah I got you
they have three they have three we have to minimize their
usage yeah so true are Are you guys ready?
I'm ready.
Mm-hmm.
Go ahead.
I slept some, I slept a dynamo.
Top right, top right, top right.
Yeah, I'm shooting, I'm shooting him.
He's almost dead.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Get the Deadpool, get the Deadpool.
He's just gonna stall for 20 years.
Oh, you might have to use a little, oh wait, you don't have
it.
I don't have it, I don't have it.
I'm 83, I'm 83.
Whoa!
99.
Oh, it says 99, 99.
Yeah.
Good win, good team win.
Look at that.
We did it.
Let's go!
Good job.
There he is.
Yeah!
Nicely done.
We're gamers.
I mean, that we won without...
How did I get into two?
You were a good ride, brother.
Guys, we won without triple support.
Oh, so true.
So true.
Crazy.
Yeah, that is insane.
38,000.
thousand is that his shield doing that wow it is a huge aoe
it's all it's all it's everything yeah i know he like
absorbs some of the damage that punisher takes when
punisher's riding him so maybe it's also that you're welcome
oh man i got gaslit guys my head mom was like oh jk they
were I was just, they were just like, sorry, I lost the
deadlock game, so I was mad at AFK.
Please have some fun.
So I got, he was like, sorry, I was in, I lost the deadlock
game, and then I was mad, so I AFK.
So I do just need more mods in general.
Wait, what?
Do you have the writing thing equipped so I could ride you
and then someone can ride me?
You know what I'm saying?
No, I don't have that one equipped.
No.
Oh.
Last, you can play Pony again, bro, if you want.
Oh, you should ride Tim.
Did you get to ride him yet?
I haven't.
No.
It's great.
It's like you don't have to press your keyboard at all.
You just aim and click.
Well, I'm like five.
Can I get someone else to, like, you know, get on?
What do you need, bro?
He's saying you're going to break his back.
Oh.
Listen, Jay, you've been preparing your whole life for this,
bro.
Listen, I can squat 700.
Okay.
You can't squat 700, bro.
No, no, no.
Hell no.
I wish.
I'm about to say that's a lot.
A solo timid tab and DPS.
This could be a questionable decision, but let's see what we
got.
I got Tim.
Yell at me if you ever need me to get on.
I'll just yell ride.
I'll yell ride.
Oh, I think he grabbed me off.
I'm already off.
Don't worry.
Oh, my God.
You guys are taking me.
so much damage right now there is so much happening where
are you see I'm on you what do you mean you kick me off I
have him I have him kill him are you is this team okay is
this team okay oh why can't I dude I'm gonna freak out so
our Dino and Punisher are not synced up I No!
No!
Okay, something I noticed is that I can't just hit C.
I gotta look at you.
Oh.
And you need...
No, I...
You just need to not hit C when I'm on here.
No, I gotta look at you to hit C though.
You keep kicking me off.
Hey, nobody's stealing Gambit's chance to win.
No!
Okay, we hold them here.
We hold them here.
True, true, true.
Fine is.
Don't worry.
We have Jeff.
I'm going to try to get him first because whoever gets him
first, yeah, get him, get him, get him, get him, get him,
get him.
Oh, I got my dinosaur.
I think that damage boost is just so strong.
Yeah, I have to grab him first so he drops the other
Punisher.
Oh, I might be dead.
He's just, yeah, he might be dead.
He had the Rokio.
That was like Godzilla coming after me.
I'm not going to lie.
Stalled the point.
Oh, here, I'll let you shoot.
back for more all right here we go okay you get oh by the
way you you do get knocked off if you hit old you do get
knocked off okay okay jeff are you craig are you having a
battle with boxing back there yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna do it
okay you're going in he's low he's he's anti too oh my god
nice nice let's go keep the high ground oh it oh can't feel
can't feel give me in there you want to get in there okay
i'm going right it's just all supports it's just all
supports oh never mind goodbye oh no no i think i think
you're dead i think you guys might be dead i'm dead boxy's
bringing me into the spawn
snap all right here we go
I got my all here.
I got mine, too.
Did they have a dinosaur all?
I do have mine.
I could drop you in the middle.
I could just pop.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good.
Taking the high ground.
Let's get this.
Oh, my God.
The dinos coming in.
I'm going to ult here.
Wait, wait.
Oh, wait.
I need out.
Wait, the punishes.
No, punishes.
Oh, never mind.
Punisher got healed.
Punisher's got healed.
They're...
Wait, they're mantises?
Oh, wait.
You guys are...
Oh
All right, oh Yeah, we're out of here.
Oh, oh You got I guess you got to disappear.
Oh, I'm just trusting my dinosaur I did
I got you right now I got a big turret position back here.
Hang on.
I'm going to hold him off.
He's a good turret.
Stand behind his turret.
And we're safe.
Yeah, yeah.
I feel so safe.
I feel so safe back here.
We're no longer safe.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Short-lived.
Don't worry.
We have our dynamo back.
Okay, I'm on him.
That means we win.
They might have gift holds soon.
Watch out.
I don't have an ulti for that, guys.
Yeah, I think we got backup.
I'm scared.
Oh, my God.
See, look at that.
Survivability.
We got that.
Oh, I'm close to, I'm close to...
Oh, they blocked.
Yeah, here.
I'm 94.
I'm not on.
Wait, I'm going to try something here.
I got it.
Damn, it's coming up.
I'm shooting up.
Oh, I tried to take off.
Wait, what happened?
Wait, what?
Jay, wait, what happened to you that?
I grabbed the dyno and I tried to jump off the back of them.
But he has his jump still.
Wait, so like, even when you...
That's crazy.
I love triple support, guys.
Oh, I can't touch.
It's okay.
They didn't kill him.
I have to run to the bathroom.
I may have to take two seconds.
BRB.
You're good.
Dino has so much HP in his old.
It's crazy.
I think we fixed...
I think we fixed our mod situation.
We should be good now.
We should be good.
Apparently, that was something that was happening on rival
streamers on Twitch where there were bots coming in raiding
people.
I don't know if anyone else got marked, but we are gonna be
looking for more NA mods later Because apparently what I
found out basically what I was being told was that a lot of
the NA mods just were just not was just not online Oh, we're
back just today.
Just today.
It was just coincidence Because usually I never got hit
before for botting stuff Do you guys mind if I die now
please?
Yeah, get it get it.
Hell yeah, I want to try.
Yeah, I want to be prehistoric man I think it was just like
it was just the timing.
Yeah, it must be whips.
Okay.
It was like because like normally nothing hits me during
when I stream on Twitch So they're like oh, it's fine if I'm
it's fine if I'm like not on today.
Uh, what do you guys want here?
We're okay now.
We're okay.
We're so back.
Oh, we're good.
We are gonna look for more N.A.
Mods that just in case make you run faster It happens again.
It's like a precaution.
Love it.
But I'm back to locking in I'm gonna penny.
I'm gonna be that guy.
Love that dude.
I'm gonna fly.
Oh, I believe you're going to play on Dino.
Don't get chomped.
Any, any, any Punisher enjoyers?
No one's going to hop on that Dino.
I am.
No, what?
The battle.
Oh, you're punny.
Okay.
I was going to say, I was going to say, I was going to say,
let's go.
Oh, how do I?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
I got to wait now.
Hold up.
Oh, now I can do.
Nice.
Let's go.
All right, very winnable.
Love it, love it.
There's only one healer up right now.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I thought we had two healers.
Oh, never mind, never mind.
I was damage boosting, sorry.
We got inviterate.
I already used up.
I was like, go throw some cards and I just saw you
disappear.
Yeah, I was just using it all as damage.
Dang, dang.
Oh, Moon Knight.
The Moon Knight is a direct counter to the freaking riding.
Coming back, coming back.
you know I'm actually gonna go moon into this I like that
nice I'm gonna give you guys here yeah yeah oh I looked away
for one second okay I'm gonna go a main healer I think I
think you guys might I got you I might need it I might need
a obliterated bot here yeah I'm going to punish her here
okay that would be the best I guess regroup regroup
Fantastic.
Actually, I feel like cook.
Because then you can just see the bubbles.
Invice to help the dinosaur and hit you.
Tell the Punisher.
Tell the Punisher!
I can't... I can't up use any more with the Moon Knight.
Oh my god.
Fair, fair, fair, fair.
I just take... Just be in a little circle.
Oh my.
Maybe I can't play Dino.
Maybe, maybe, maybe bad.
He's got to leave, I believe.
You got to leave.
never your fault yeah yeah it's it's the dps as well not
creating space for the dino i bet that's my trick go go
phoenix nice love it love it oh yeah how does new phoenix
feel okay we're happy i got nice let's go let's go okay i
got i got my oil here too for you guys so much damage the
moon night is crazy you and i reflect in each other
Wow.
I got mine.
I think they're playing bully our dinosaur.
That's messed up.
Yeah, I think they're shooting.
They're doing everything they can to shoot at you.
Moxie is not riding their dino, so I...
It's like...
I can't get the Aok bounce.
Okay, I have to get off.
Oh, wait, wait, we got...
We got their party.
You don't have it?
Okay, okay, okay, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Yeah, we're gonna close up, we're gonna close, we're gonna
close on the right.
Nice, dead.
Uh-oh.
I'm gonna jump, I'm gonna jump, jump, jump, jump.
Huge.
Elton's on the right side!
Elton on the right side!
I don't think, I...
I'm not sure, actually.
Yeah, she did, she did, she did.
She got an extra movement.
Oh, nice.
That shot him.
Three seconds off your E, I believe.
Judge, jury.
I got my knee.
Oh, wow.
He was getting healed.
But he's low.
Oh, no.
Not the punishment.
I just want to ult once.
You're almost there.
No, I'm so close.
I'm so close.
Oh, my God.
He hits those.
Somebody else can, uh, you see that?
Play this monster.
This is why I didn't play that.
That could have been me.
Yep.
Yeah, I see that.
You know, you know, they're dying.
I could have been me.
So I was like, sorry, anyone else can play Dino.
They won.
Oh, they buffed her.
They buffed her.
They buffed fighting.
Her nuts, like, go way faster now.
I think.
Finally, Squirrel Me's can rise up.
The moon haunts you.
Oh, you're so stupid.
I'm in there.
I'm a Squirrel Girl player.
Me right out.
Where I got you?
Oh, I'm back.
I'm back.
I'm behind you.
Behind you, behind you.
He's on point.
Oh, he's not.
Dude, dude, I have my own.
I have my own.
It's over for them.
Oh, nice.
They see nine.
I believe there's only two of you.
That's okay.
We got the point.
We can die.
Yeah, we got point.
We got we die for a sacrifice.
You coming?
I'm big and slow.
We're here.
Nice, nice, nice.
noise just left clicking or right I here and I got my old oh
this is it this is your moment to shine yeah are we ready
are we going to go in we're going in I'm ready I mean oh
baby oh never mind maybe not maybe not no we're not going in
no no no no no no no we lost okay okay we're going in we're
not we're not going in I'm helping you on Environmental
Spider-Man no no
realize i was res the light always comes back uh spider-man
okay okay all right i think now we could go in i'm just
gonna go in i'm gonna go in yeah just go in we are oh
yeah that jeffy is such a good camera he's a great counter
yeah how are we in a big night only counter dying this is an
early access stream i'm getting the shark i'm getting the
shark i don't care anymore come here
Alas, is you down to get a little freaky with the ult?
Yeah, absolutely.
Once we get a little space here.
Oh, hold on.
My man on us.
Okay, it's a good thing we did it because I would have been
dead.
Oh.
Hey, does anybody else want to...
Does anybody else want to dino?
Does anybody else...
You're doing great.
I believe.
Okay.
You're not at 20 deaths yet.
You're good.
That can change.
You're doing fantastic.
They're running the triple support focus the they might show
we know they're not triple guys to say they're ready We're
winning the vibes So true so true you win the mental yeah,
we're here shows how dynos truly played Let's go.
Let's go Oh my god, he's one but that's fine about nice Oh
I'm backing out.
Okay, you're gonna you're on your own I think we go goats.
I think.
Oh, what?
I think goats is the way.
You know, can we go goats?
Goats.
Hear me out.
Are we at this?
I'll throw, I'll throw my own, that's why.
Thank God.
All right.
I'm going to do, I'm going to, oh, God.
Is that, are we all good?
Are we all good?
Where's the Spider-Man?
Oh, I'm going to try to do crazy.
Moxie is literally trolling, bro.
He's trolling.
Wait, he's half.
He's so low.
We need the pain brothers.
Oh, my God.
Let's see here.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
I had another five.
Okay, okay.
I love to hear it.
Good call him.
All right.
I'm going to pull Hail Mary here.
Are we ready?
The sharks are going to come in and eat me now, maybe?
He's going to eat you.
Eat you?
Yeah he ate me.
Oh, he's so low.
We got it.
Winnable.
I'm coming back, guys.
I'm still alive.
I'm on a card.
There's one.
He's getting killed.
You're not going to die on me, bro.
We're good, we're good.
We're all good.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm shooting my gun.
It's over time now.
Surely they have nothing else.
But I'm going to let you heal.
Okay.
I'm sad.
I'm sad, babe.
I'm gonna heal Just keep picking damage.
You're good, you're good.
One, the Donato's was one.
All right.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice.
He's low, he's low, he's low, he's low.
Oh my God, he's on blade now.
Wait, I hear someone behind us.
He's going to move.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
We got winnable, winnable.
Yeah, we got this.
We got this.
Keep believing, keep believing.
Nice, nice.
Nice, he wasted it.
It's fine.
I died for the cause.
Oh, no, I had.
We got point.
Yeah, we got point.
Ooh.
Nice.
That's fine.
I should respawn is next to the truck.
Let's go.
Oh, this is looking like a Jeff Engel now.
Oh, I got my old.
Oh, that's true.
I'm gonna wait till we kill Jeff before I old, because he's
just gonna eat me and my old every time.
Hoppies, hoppies.
If we can focus Jeff and then call it out.
Oh, my God.
I mean, first off, you have to live, be alive.
Oh, yeah, I'm trying.
I'm trying.
Oh, he's one.
He's one.
Oh, you're so low, though.
Oh, Batman one.
Spider-Man one left side.
He ran away.
Oh, wait.
Who shot?
Oh, there, wait.
There's a blade behind us.
Oh.
There's so many people behind us.
Oh, crap.
Uh-oh.
Don't you put me out.
Oh.
This is winnable.
You gotta believe team.
Just keep believing.
I believe.
Wait, Jeff is dead.
I can go alt.
Okay, you gotta go like in five seconds.
He's gonna come back now.
He's gonna, oh, I'll, when he...
Oh, there he is.
No, there he is.
No!
This is illegal.
I'm shooting my gun.
Three, two, one.
They're gonna go your lap.
Huge, huge, huge.
Wait, there's two, there's two people behind us.
I'm low.
I'm low over.
We're doing it!
I'm also doing it!
Let me build up.
Huge, huge.
98.
No.
Nice nut, Tim.
I saw that on the Spider-Man.
Thank you, bro.
I'm nutting.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Nut on the dino.
Oh, my God.
Body blocked it.
Nice.
Body blocked.
Oh, my.
Wait, I'm on that.
I'm doing the shotgun.
The combos.
Oh, nice design!
Let's go!
All right, yeah, we're so good.
Everybody close their eyes.
Don't look at my final hits.
Close your eyes.
No, no, that's normal.
You created space.
I'm literally playing Squirrel Girl all season A, bro.
They buffed her nut speed.
It's crazy.
Oh, you're playing Rogue.
Oh, I'll play Rogue too, yeah.
You're just role-playing the moment when the meteorites
strike the earth.
Commonly, it's fine.
I love it a little bit.
I'm a plant eater.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
Is it just this map?
Yeah, it kind of looks that way.
But I think we're doing the three dinosaurs and three
punishers now.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
The last 30 minutes, right?
you should nine oh nice oh i saw what happened to avalie i
don't know but we won that game we won that game for some
great tanking we won we did that's true that's just she
created a lot of space for us 100 i don't where are we doing
three you have three buddy my my thing says i think it's at
40 five 45.
yeah yeah someone say to do it now oh no
Oh, my bad, my bad, my bad.
Come on, bro.
Get a little man hands up.
A little sneak peek.
Oh, my God.
Anybody want dinosaur?
All you.
It's all you.
Have you played him yet?
Yeah, I've played him once.
Who hasn't played him yet?
Okay, all right.
I'll do it once.
I can't wait to get shot at by six people.
No, no, no, I'm going to focus you.
I heard the cries of...
pain homily i heard you crying chat chat hear me out a rare
timid tap man bp angle bro rare oh my yeah love it wait we
don't even have a punish you who's gonna ride i'm a i'm a
rideless dino oh my god he's got no riot i could change no
jockey i'm focusing good luck everyone else i think i'm
gonna swap
I couldn't chop.
Oh, I need.
Thank you.
I got you.
I shot him.
I'm throwing him over.
Oh, never mind.
I died.
He's low though.
He's low.
He's dead.
Oh my god.
Huge.
Let him cook.
I'm sorry.
I let you die, Doki.
Like you're Genji, bro.
I feel like we need like four supports to keep me alive.
Live.
That's how I felt.
Wait, so what do you see the TikTok clip of this, bro?
You're going to hear Tremmoot.
I've seen the entire team getting killed, bro.
Oh, shit.
I'm dead.
I thought you were trying to say, like, your voice line
didn't go off because you died.
No.
Where the fuck do I take space here?
Get ready.
Oh, bro.
No.
We're damaging.
Oh, I died.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Give me out of here.
I forgot they could see me through the wall there.
Oh, man.
I'm trying to peel.
But he chopped on me.
Almost back.
It's big.
Oh, duh.
Oh.
I died.
I'm 99 to my own now.
Oh, it's so close.
It's okay.
We're more of a second point team.
Yeah, yeah, that's true.
That's true.
We're always second point.
Yeah.
I'm back, I'm back.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck did you do, Jay?
Oh, my God.
This guy's too good.
I kind of wanted to solo ult someone, but they all kind of
lined up in her right now.
Who was your solo target?
I don't know.
Whoever went into my building, but they all walked in my
building.
Yeah, yeah.
Go away.
I'm going to ult you.
I'm going to ult you this one.
He'll.
Here you go.
Let's kill it.
I'm swallowed.
I'm shielding, but I don't think I'll live.
I live Nice nice nice.
Yeah, there's a mr.
Fantastic on me My god, oh, give me out of here.
Get me out of here.
I'm trying.
I'm trying my god I'm trying to save you.
Oh my god.
I almost have I got you.
I got you for you Yeah, yeah, kill that dino kill that dino.
Oh, he's so low.
He got out.
No, I don't have beams left My laser beam ran out who is
super just wrong?
into my clip i have three oh that's okay i got you thank you
thank you thank you i'm trying to i got you i'm taking i'm
taking oh gosh i'm just i'm just scared they're alive i'm
just watching a dinosaur just bounce get out oh why are they
all so much heals nice nice oh god oh look at What is going
on?
Guys, there might be a dinosaur behind us.
There might be a dinosaur behind us.
I got you.
Where, where, where?
Oh my God.
How's he over there?
I don't know.
He jumped back.
I tried.
I'm trying to help you.
I'm just chomping.
Oh no, Tim.
I got you.
Oh, you show him.
You show him.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Placer beams.
Oh, okay.
I'm still chomping.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
I'm chomping still.
As you should, as you should.
That's why I chomped you back.
I've been watching two dinosaurs fight for three minutes.
No one's dying.
No, we're still alive.
Wait, he's one.
He's like, I got him.
Nice, nice.
We're doing it.
Good stuff.
Oh, yeah.
I feel like I'm just the goddamn sponge.
We are the best team.
Yeah.
Oh.
I had to pull up my main.
Right.
Or just go in.
Like, they're all so far.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Please stop sucking.
Yo, let him cook.
Let him cook, chat.
Let him cook, bro.
That's it.
I'm gonna, I'm going in.
Oh, you're really low.
I'm going in.
It's fine.
I live forever.
Don't worry.
I got you guys.
nice nice oh he's so nice we shot him nice which one which
one did i know there's too many dynos dino dip dino dip all
right they have their dino i got mine oh my god stop
There's a lot of damage, by the way, for this.
Oh, my gosh.
Where am I?
I think you're lost.
Enemy.
Enemy, Jeff.
I don't even know where I am.
Oh, my bad, my bad, my bad, my bad.
This is where I die.
All right, here we go.
Oh, okay.
You know what else?
All right.
We're all here.
It's just unkillable.
That is true.
I feel like we've been trying so hard.
We're killing them.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
Going up, chomping.
Push, push, push.
We're chomping.
We're still chomping.
Bad, bad, bad.
Yo, come here, come here, come here, come here.
Oh, god, I need help.
Trying to keep you up.
I need help.
I need you.
Obviously, I have shield.
I got you, Jay.
I know Flats is bad off of that one.
Oh, you keeping me up there was insane.
I got you.
Oh, he slept me.
Oh, snap.
Go get him, Doki.
He's up coming over.
Oh, he's seeking me back, too.
All you can eat, buffet, bud.
What, dude?
I'm getting my one, okay?
You don't cranky.
Oh, shit.
I'm dead, too.
Oh, no.
Someone quick, strange portal.
Are we strange portaling?
I don't think we can make it, honestly.
Oh, no, yeah, you're right.
It's okay.
We're a third point team.
Third point team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
We can totally hold this.
Oh, snap.
There's a show crag with no, never mind.
It just shows you an emergency state for me.
Weird.
Let's get him full.
Oh, that guy was so low.
I know.
That guy's so low.
That's so low.
Oh, we can still kill him.
We can still kill him.
I'm gonna go join him.
I'm scared.
Oh, snap.
you ate everyone i got three don't worry oh i used my tire
on the thank you thank you thank you thank you oh okay
that's awkward wait we could push up we have so many people
dead did you push him oh dino dino behind behind yeah he
jumped he went fantastic and went off the map oh no it truly
was fantastic oh snap
I feel like I died.
Oh my god, I'm lightheaded from that one.
Oh my god, wait.
I'm going back, I'm going back.
It's like Tim just got it.
I created space for him.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god.
Oh snap.
Wait, how are you so good at BP?
Yeah, you like that?
How are you so good at BP?
Tell me you saw that kill on those supports, bro.
You like that?
Oh my god.
I might be him bro.
He's like a prodigy.
I might have to be, I might have to have a new main.
Yo yo, I'm ready.
I got you.
I'm not gonna let you guy.
Nice, nice, nice.
Shark Ultid, Shark Ultid.
Oh wait.
Oh, there I'm in there.
I'm in it.
I'm in, I'm in it.
The fuck.
That goes vibrating right now.
Goodbye.
This is where I die.
The meteor hit me.
I got you.
I got, I got both.
Thank you.
I don't have you.
I lied to you.
I'm a liar That's how she's gonna get trust issues This is
gonna take one fight team and we got this guys one fight
This guy is like I'll chop your way never mind.
I guess oh shit Okay, we're not chopping we're not chopping.
We got a regroup fully.
We are saving alts for this last fight, right?
fight is all it takes team i'm gonna go straight wait do
they have jeff i don't think so i'll try to kill jeff jeff
is not at all oh wait that i'm breaking i'm in all i'm in
all oh my god yeah yeah yeah oh fantastic camping me at the
door i got him dinosaur they have no dinosaur they have no
Oh, I
got kick off.
The title didn't pick you.
Come on, boy.
The title didn't pick me.
Hold the warcraft.
Give them a mouse.
Do I pass inspection?
All right, guys, we have to win.
I just spray and pray, right?
Love it.
We got to win.
We got this.
We don't have heals, so it's a little...
They have spawn and we don't.
We're gonna set up on a flank or something.
We should fight around like here, yeah?
Are we gonna give him the flank and the spank?
All right, you ready for that?
All right.
Chad, if you spam that I'm a stormtrooper again, I'm gonna
ban everyone.
Oh my god!
Flank and spank, flank and spank.
Give it back up.
I'm already dead.
We're all dead.
No, no, no, we're waiting, we're waiting, we're waiting.
Oh, yeah, we lost only two dinos.
Heel back, heal back!
Heel back.
We have fast spawns.
They have fast spawns.
They also have a spawn to heal, which is a little scary.
Guys, I have a great idea.
Wait, everyone should go.
A new owner.
Grab that.
Hey, yo, everyone, group up.
Hear me out.
We sit in the same spot and we rotate shields, bro.
Rotate shields.
Oh, okay, okay.
Who's first?
Oh, smart.
We ready?
Okay, hang on.
Hang on.
I'm waiting for Jen.
Wait for Jen.
Okay, we're missing our passenger.
Oh, my God.
Wait, who's doing shields first?
Okay, last, you're first.
Okay, okay, okay.
Tell me when you're gone.
Tell me where's guy?
I'm jumping in!
I'm jumping in.
I'm going!
Where did you get?
Oh!
Where's your shoot?
Wait, oui!
Oh, shit!
Oh god!
Oh, I'm so low!
I'm so low.
I'm down!
Ah, I'm down!
Huge, good rotation!
Nice, nice rotation.
Oh my god, you're so low!
Retreat!
How much health do you have?
Two health.
All right.
I gotta get health real fast.
Come on.
Okay.
Go back.
No, not that.
Oh, no.
That's a great.
All right.
Two.
There you go.
I do the same thing last.
You shield first.
Okay.
Don't keep sucking.
I'm 30.
Okay.
Where's that?
Oh, no.
I'm getting shot from the right.
It's okay.
I'm shielding.
We're going in.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, I got knocked off.
I got knocked off.
Oh, I'm shooting next.
You know, it was working until it wasn't.
They had the advantage.
They had the heel spawn.
That's so true.
They do have the advantage right now.
We got to take some off angles.
We actually got one to the other spawn.
That's my bad.
I'm trying to hop on you, bro.
We're going to give him the sneaky.
I like this.
Oh, oh, oh, go!
Oh my God.
It's like I can't see.
We break it.
Go, go, go, go, go!
I'm with thenos.
Oh, I think our team went us down there a little.
I did a prepire a little bit.
No shields.
Oh, that's you right there.
Wait, that's huge.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wait, do you have shields?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I do.
I'm going in, I'm going in.
Oh, no more shields, no more shields!
They also have xeered.
This is a dinosaur's one.
The dinosaur's one.
You're alone, you're alone.
Oh That dinosaur is not one.
Oh, no The other dinosaur was not one It was a different
dinosaur I'm coming back off spawn Oh, goodbye The dinosaur
didn't pick you, I'm sorry Oh snap I don't have shield, I
fucked up dude Oh god Oh, they ulted, they ulted I let you
down That's okay, that's okay, that's fine Oh, I can all
hear.
He's weak.
He's kind of weak.
He's bleeding.
They're so low.
Oh, we got one of them.
Go, go, go, go.
All right, guys, if we win this fight, we hold this point.
We have the spawn advantage, okay?
I have ult too.
Should I ult?
Wait, you guys have to go now then.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
I want to ult.
I'm gonna ult.
Nice, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
I'm dead.
No, no, I got a couple of them though.
Spawn advantage.
Go back to spawn and heal.
Go to spawn in here.
I'm going spawn.
Actually, you got two health packs that can almost get you
up.
There's three.
Yo, their health packs are like in a triangle, bro.
Nice, nice, nice.
All right.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't see you.
Sorry, I was so big.
I couldn't see you.
I'm going to alt here.
Oh, it's going to be fun.
Wait, wait.
They're all there on the right.
They're grouping up.
They're getting for the raid.
Let's do this guys.
Are we ready?
Are they on the left?
They're coming.
They're coming, right?
Oh my.
Oh,
I might be dead here.
There's too many dinos.
He's one.
We got one.
No!
Still durable.
Oh, dang.
We always were.
That's right.
There's so many dinos.
We gotta lock in.
I'm the red Dino.
Alright.
Why is it not...
I clicked on somebody.
There you go.
Oh, that's huge.
That's so good.
That's good.
I got him.
I got him off the...
We're doing it.
Nice, nice, nice.
One by this corner.
Oh, we got him.
I need a shield.
Nice, nice, nice.
We're on the Heel packs.
Yeah, I got it.
Let me try something.
I like it.
That could be gross.
Oh, yeah.
They're down.
Oh, well.
You could be crazy.
Okay.
Here we go.
We're doing the flank in Spain.
I got flats.
We got this.
My favorite maneuver.
Here we go.
Go, go, go, go.
Oh, shit.
He got me.
He's one Go so close Go so close It's now or never stop them
All right, here we are Nice nice Ow ow Ow Gotta wait Nice
nice How do we have the health pack?
Yeah or a health pack in here?
We'll never expect this Oh my god Oh my god Oh you're so low
I love it I love it I love it I got him off I got him off I
have a dinosaur that's one I got a dinosaur Nice, nice.
Oh, bob, bob, bob, bob, bob, bob, bob, bob.
Get in here.
Oh, my God, he got me.
Got two.
He's on the turret.
Wait, that is my...
Good job.
That's so smart.
Oh, jump up your gym if you can.
Should I turn them off?
Twitch, Twitch have three turrets in the back.
They'll never expect it.
I'm dead.
I'm going to die off this, but I'm dead.
Go get on me.
Hear me out.
Three turrets, three die.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I got him off, but then he fucking bit me back.
Wait, this is the last fight.
This is the last fight.
Hear me out.
Three turrets.
Hear me.
They ain't pushing.
They ain't pushing, bro.
Oh, shit.
They might be pushing.
Oh, my God.
I couldn't even use my own.
he's happy you have to get on it no no winnable winnable
just get out the point I got it I got the point huge huge
huge huge we have we have spawn advantage we have spawn
advantage I'm better I'm better I'm better spawn advantage
spawn advantage nice go heal go heal I'm going okay we might
have used all our alts I have mine I'm gonna have mine maybe
I can make something happened with it oh my god i did not
realize there were six of them there you're good this may
not be good why are you gonna die i have my own this might
be the punishers i might have taken j to the to die i tried
that was a good game that was a wild
Nice, nice.
I'm going to have to get a firing squad there.
That was my bad.
I thought that was one guy.
It was not one guy.
One guy.
He's one?
Wait.
Oh, okay.
GG's, guys.
Oh, GG's.
Have a good one.
GG's, everybody.
Make it easy, James, guys.
Hey, bye.
All right.
Bye, my guys.
Bye.
Have a good one.
Oh, that was fun.
That's crazy.
Okay, his hitbox is fucking insane.
Yeah.
Yeah, baited Jay.
I was like, all right, Jay, let's go in.
All right, dude, die, I guess.
It's so rough about you.
I was like, with the multiple Punisher smoke bomb.
I was like, where is everyone?
I can't see.
I'm just chomping.
Where are the people?
I was literally fighting blind.
but show to the mods for handling the the raid the raids i
didn't realize how bad it got for rivals for the bot raids
also yet again i'll still be playing rivals i'm just gonna
swap to the main client because i haven't the other marvel
rival sponsor um but apparently uh apparently it's been
going on for a while um in uh in the rivals category so i i
thought it was i thought it was still going on um but we are
going to be adding more mods uh just an emergency sake uh
because usually you know we never had to encounter stuff
like that before so um just as a precaution apparently it's
just this category is getting uh hit right now yeah it was
my first time i ever got like bot rated too um they only
killed one innocent bystander are they truly innocent though
We know they're really innocent, though.
All right, let me boot it up real quick.
Yes, it was me.
Sure, bro.
You're definitely innocent.
Yeah.
Who else got raided?
I know, apparently it wasn't just me.
It was like, uh, other people also got hit.
Let's see.
Alright.
Oh, the Tim and Super also got it.
Got hit.
Yeah, we made it about- don't jinx this.
Don't- I'm not- I didn't want to mention it because I don't
know.
I don't know if I'm going to crash later on.
But I didn't crash during the sponsor.
It was great.
I didn't crash during the sponsor, which is all I need.
Um.
Maybe I won't play on my main or oh, everybody's screaming
right now
I'll play I'll play on an alt account Let's see.
I'm gonna play on the oh, I can't I fuck I keep forgetting a
cat That's the worst part wait Technically, I can I just got
started Start my vtuber stuff off stream an off stream um I
have to start it on But but but I have to start it Off
steam.
That's what I mean.
Alright, let me boot it up on steam then.
Alright, I gotta swap.
Wait, unless... No, I can't.
Wait, do I... Can I have a load?
No, fuck!
I don't have a loading bay.
Alright, I don't have a loading bay.
I can't.
I mean.
Um...
Alright, I'll disappear for us.
I'm gonna disappear.
Abercudabra.
because i need to boot this up off steam okay let's see
browse local files where is it start without steam there it
is and then i'm glad they have a start without steam um i
start no steam area function so now i can swap accounts
accounts all right
account swapped abracadabra I'm back oh oh don't worry
abracadabra I'm back there was a little delay all right let
me get on my other account all right we're gonna go on the
knock dokey bird account surely no one will know it's me how
would they know oh yeah and then let me i'm back guys it's
like i never left okay uh all right let me start the other
sponsor back with another marvel rival sponsor doing
campaign details uh how do i start it it's been so long
since i've been on here enable there you go enable channel
skin there you go professional streamer here here, by the
way.
I've been doing this for at least five years now.
All right.
Here we go.
Marvel Rivals brand new 1v6 PvP.
The Avengers mode is now live.
Jump into this asymmetric showdown.
Choose to play as Loki or fight alongside the Avengers.
Entirely free for all players.
Explore the Avengers themed events in Times Square,
including movie watch parties and Easter eggs.
Don't miss out on all the fresh new content.
Oh, this stream is sponsored by Marble Rivals.
Yay!
There you go.
Everything is great.
For free?
Yes!
For free!
It's a free game!
You can play it right now!
Latina, leave with Twitch Prime, thank you.
Thank you.
XMT, thank you for tier one.
So, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, thank you, everybody.
Thank you, Dragons, for spam um that's crazy the spam was
fucking insane i never realized it got that bad but we made
it we made it through our first bot raid
all right
there's this monitor all right this is my not jokie beard
account see not jokie beard look at my play tab look at how
bad this went
okay and then it didn't go pretty okay I was like oh my god
guys look at me go I'm I'm doing it guys I'm doing oh but
wait wait I played I love oh
Well, anyway, I'm not going to be playing Tank on here.
I'm just going to be chilling.
Let's see if... Let me double check something real quick.
But yes, we're going to be playing more Mavid Alamos.
I don't want to play my main.
My main is on eternity.
I don't really want to...
I don't really want to grind too much.
I don't want to grind on eternity right now.
Just want to...
Just want to chill.
so let's get right to it
for the portal right yeah but huge shout out for the mods
for coming back it was just unfortunate timing it was just
unfortunate timing for oh I'm finally shaders again that
they everybody was just like doing something else because
they're like oh it should be fun usually we don't get hit
but yeah shout out to the mods for all like coming in um
just coming in the moment um the moment everybody realized
all right here we go wait i think the worst part about on my
alt account is that i don't have all the good stuff i should
start i don't have all the good um all my favorite skins and
favorite emotes why does he stop dancing this this is
censorship ship why does he stop dancing when did they add
this update when did they nerf him I don't feel like playing
you know what I'm playing white flock it's GM it should be
fine can't be that bad oh yes but yes we're gonna have the
new mods we're bringing in they're more they're gonna be
volunteer mods so um we're gonna have a new system silent
mods are the paid staff and then the non-silent mods are um
and then i believe the non from the non-paid the non-paid
mods are gonna not have the silent names so the silent army
the silent army would be the more the uh the senior dokey
staff yeah
That's how they were looking at how we're doing
And they're going to be looking Yeah Yeah so they're going
to be renames among the silent team Also Wait which silent
team is going to be Got which Wait which Silent which
silence are going to be renamed
Which silent are we here Are we renaming Inside of you there
are two Silence
Are we still in sub mode?
Wait, I think we're...
Alright, I'm going to turn sub mode off.
There we go.
I just realized that.
Oh, come on.
I wanted to play White Fox.
You guys are freed now.
Come forth.
Freedom!
Were the other streamers on sub mode as well?
And they are free!
You are free now!
And then the bots start rolling in.
I was like, nope, go back in the cage, guys.
Get back in.
I just realized, I didn't even notice.
I was just like, wait a minute.
There's a lot of badges in here.
Free.
You now have rights to speak.
Freedom.
Were the other streamers also on sub-mode?
Or were they just like actively banned?
Well, I don't want to get followed by it, though.
That's the thing.
Yeah, but they have a lot of bot.
Oh, they went follow mode?
Deal with it?
That's smart.
Oh, you like that?
Oh, man, I should heal myself.
I didn't even realize there was a...
Oh my god, I didn't realize we're going like such low heels
I hate this map.
There's a reason they like literally took this map of
rotation and then did nothing to it
What the fuck Hey guys I mean it wasn't a good idea for to
try and push
Oh my god.
Oh, where did the squirrel girl come from?
Oh my god, how did she see?
Oh, she didn't even see me.
She was looking at the goddamn hot guy.
The hot guy threw away my positioning.
Yeah, we do follow mode next time.
We're learning, guys.
We not learn about not pushing up too much.
Oh, I can't see where...
They're strangers getting harassed so much.
Oh, I'm frame dropping.
Don't worry, keep flying!
He wants to land on me, but he couldn't!
I saw it.
He was like getting ready.
He was setting up the dive and everything.
That's right.
You try to pull...
Oh my god.
right he set up a guy he set it up you still set it up
holy this i will say this adam is so aggressive wait we got
okay it's slowly pushing back all right i guess i'll push
cart now i'll push cart don't worry What the fuck?
Enemy located.
Fucking free.
What is wrong with this cloak, bro?
There's no way I was gonna say there's no way she escaped.
What is this elo?
Why would you do that?
You give me a squirrel girl, I can tell.
I got it.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
They double support ulted.
That's fine.
I'll take those.
No worries.
I got your back.
Get that sword out of here.
Yeah, I was like, so what are you doing, bro?
Why are you solo ulting point?
animated bro you're a lord animated cloak player i i think
he needs a new main
oh i that up oh my god that sucks i didn't think he would go
right or left base jab cloak and dagger I just think that
maybe that character might not be for him.
Oh, oh, oh.
Dodge.
Okay, if a mag didn't give me that shield, I would have
died.
It was just crazy.
Oh, it's fine.
They're having a monk.
I am a lot soon.
Oh, fuck that guy in particular.
Oh, my bad.
Oh, it's okay.
We all die here without using end.
Oh, nice.
It's fine.
Yep.
Why can't you kill me?
Okay.
Let's get it.
There you go.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's like going... I was like, why am I not dying?
I want to use the Adam rest too.
I...
It's not fear!
Venom!
The fact that he couldn't...
I want to use it.
I'm just gonna assume that...
Oh, yep, I was gonna say I was gonna assume that he's gonna
kill him.
Oh, I missed the puller.
I didn't get better at the puller.
It's been a while.
Bro, Adam is so aggressive.
Alright, nice.
Yeah!
That Venom off was pretty sad.
It was.
Three, two, zero.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
Who are the reason?
I don't know who they are.
Which silence or me remain?
There you go.
Yeah, three cap.
That's pretty easy.
All right, top two.
I still don't like this map.
I don't know.
I just don't like first point very much.
This team cop is so good.
No, this team cop is...
I don't know about him, but this is not...
I don't know how we're making this team cop work.
We're literally doing Adam.
This Adam is just fighting.
He's just fighting for his own life.
Loud.
That'd be funny.
Changing the loud.
What the fuck?
Oh, no, there's a glitch in the matrix.
All right, here we go.
The item just wants to beat people up.
He doesn't even want to heal.
He's just like, I guess he's like, you get healed when I
heal.
When...
Oh, my god.
What?
Oh, it's because of the soul bond.
I was like, I am not taking that much damage.
I should not be taking that much damage.
holy shit so much damage right now a random bullshit
squirrel girl is fucking us up all right that's right you do
a little jump you get pulled back
got you oh
goodbye rocket okay i got you boys i'm gonna avoid the cloak
on the enemy team i just i'm still thinking about that cloak
all we saw that one fight that's in my head i was like what
what possessed you to do that like hey i i would have been
very mad if he was on my team i would say that i i was like
why did you think that was a good idea like what are you
gonna do 1v6 with your cloak oh
i should have kept the rose i should have just let him Is he
doing a die on point at res?
Yes, he is.
I don't think he saw us.
Don't worry, die on point.
He has res.
Just die on point.
He's gonna res us.
Just keep dying on point.
He's not as fantastic as I thought it would be.
That stranger is getting bullied so hard.
He's not even solo tanking.
He's just not having fun.
Yeah, end of season.
Good old end of season games.
See, this is why I also don't want to play on my main right
now.
During end of season.
I mean, okay.
I mean, oh my god, this Phantom.
his best oh okay nice goodbye i'll never see you again i'm
gonna make sure i i will make sure i never see you again i
okay nice i'll make sure i'm sorry but that i literally
stood there asking him to kill me somehow fucked up his alt
because I didn't get bubbled and I was alive standing still
waiting for the atom res for like at least three seconds and
that was so sad that I was so I was like come on kill me I
needed I wanted to be res too to the enemy team may we never
meet again
Oh, those are boys.
I had to make sure.
Oh, no.
They have the two good DPS players, though.
Okay, can I play White Fox now?
Yeah.
I remember, like, two of them were top 500s.
One season one, but still.
I'm going to go use the bathroom while they do the bans.
I'll be right back, guys.
Pick your hero or villain.
not judging
oh i'm back sorry yeah i'm muted myself but uh rika i think
it was your one sub thank you thank you he's so big his
hitbox dd dd dinosaur double dinosaur it's crazy like you
have to hard pocket him or he but you don't even get all
charged off of hard pocketing though that's the thing He's
such an ult sponge that like, but then like you don't even
get up that fast.
And he's like, like he's so killable.
You know when we were doing like the 2-2-2 Punisher battle
thing?
I died so fast.
I took so, I absorbed so much damage and I died so fucking
fast.
Yeah, I think you gotta play him triple support or he's
never gonna live.
I was doing like I feel like some the supports when the
supports are um when the when he's on the supports or if
he's on like he does so much damage like by himself without
even a Punisher
okay oh my god my squad bad for music we're taking too much
damage already
Oh, I'm dead.
I fucked up there.
I should not have TP'd.
I should not have TP there.
I don't know.
I thought I was unstoppable.
Okay, but what if...
No, I should actually go to Cloak.
It's not.
I thought I was...
I thought I was invincible.
I wanted to play, but...
Because Cloak isn't bad, she's just a better character.
She's just better overall.
Oh my god, you are crazy for just standing there I'm not
Mark, I mean Mark Grayson I would say invincible Power
scaling is all over the place You would think that he's
getting stronger, but he's not Every time he just I feel
like he's just getting his shit beat in I don't I don't
think he's that strong ever.
Oh, what the fuck?
What?
Where's my shield?
He fucking stopped shield!
Alright.
Now I feel we're gonna lose because the enemy team have
like, top five of your players.
Let me push up guys.
Alright.
I can't wait for Cyclops' punch rate, punch eyes.
or punch lasers for those who don't know fun fact the lasers
aren't actually lasers they're kinetic punches they're
kinetic blasts blasts so they're just punching i feel like
i'm just gonna die from the hawkeye if i oh so i don't know
i mean i can try watch me die
oh i walked that way because i knew i could die where's my
okay oh where dead here unless yay not yet goodbye it's no
longer yay our tank for some reason didn't come to us
oh no longer yay no they're i think they're like dps top 500
duo
catch it no He couldn't catch it!
I just didn't want to get hit.
Please!
Oh, I need to change my title.
We're not early access anymore.
Wait, can one of my mods change the title?
To...
Uh...
Oh my god.
To...
Oh, actually, alt account.
Elo terrorized terrorism or end of season terrorism.
How?
I've never stopped holding left click.
No, he's definitely dead.
They're all definitely dead.
Wait.
Yeah.
All right, let me do this.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
I got it here.
I said hi, dokey bird.
The fuck said hi.
Dokey, I'm sorry.
Who?
Who the hell is dokey bird?
Who the hell isn't dokey bird?
This guy.
And what do they do?
It's not dokey bird.
I can tell you that much.
It's obviously not me.
Okay, let me...
You look...
You know what you are?
Terrorizing.
Playing well.
I'll take care of it.
And...
Alright.
It's totally not me.
The only way to prove it is to go dead.
If I go take, no, then it's obviously not dokey, but she'll
never go take.
Yeah, bro, let's not see the not part.
They'll be like, um, it says not dokey, right?
I'm gonna get headshot.
That's the scary part.
Alright, are you guys ready?
Okay, I'm no longer.
you're ready I'm so scared of his ult though all right but
they like oh fuck no
okay we're okay breaking the all at this in case I'm like so
scared I'm so scared of the hot guy as a cloak there oh my
god okay it's
Where's, where, where did he, where did the Neymar go?
It's terrifying.
If you cloak ulting into the, I try to go into the portal
and I was like, oh wait, the portal doesn't exist yet.
I was just like, oh yeah, there is no portal.
The game just started.
Like whoops.
Hell yeah.
Yeah, the rat goes like, don't worry, the portal will save
me!
Jokes on you.
There never was a portal.
Oh my god.
We have to help our team, so I need you to get...
Okay, never mind, I guess not.
I'll just say, we should get closer to our team in this.
I shouldn't peel.
We shouldn't be peeling away from my team.
The light always comes back.
Maybe I should just go raccoon.
Because they do have...
Oh, because they do have a...
I mean...
Oh, I willed again.
They do have a Hawkeye.
Never miss.
And I'm here, they can't kill me.
That's not Hawkeye.
Yeah, who's farming that one?
Oh my god!
Who is farming that guy?
Oh, I'm trying to keep you up
Please kill the hot guy so I can live oh Shit no I was gonna
up
I was gonna up too.
I just didn't I didn't realize the Thor was literally right
behind us
Catch it catch it catch it Okay, you're gonna pull Let's
hope I don't die.
Alright, get ready.
Watch me get headshot.
Yes, ready?
Thank you for the red.
Thank you, thank you.
I've got a good stream.
Alright, who...
What?
Okay, alright.
I ulted first.
My noise was up there.
Wait, watch me.
Watch me blind the res.
I will say that I did Oh wait I'm saved I did Alt first I
blinded the Heels guys do you see that Wait no I wanted to
play Rocket
Yeah that Jeff saved me I was like my hero Okay that's
actually good That was like the only thing I was afraid of
Hey, the only issue, we might not have it anymore.
That might be the only oopsie.
And we have Blade.
That's also the other concern.
They don't know.
I'm right behind him.
Oh, they might know now.
They don't know.
Look at our rocket, girl.
Look at him go doing his job.
Please tell me he's still doing his job.
Please.
Look at him, go.
Doing such a good job.
I'm going to play for Aash.
No, not this time.
I need to rest my voice.
I have two streams tomorrow, too.
But yeah, we got had a great stream at Limu's place.
I'm just gaming as usual.
Just been on Twitch because of a rival sponsor.
All
right, here we go.
I actually wanted to play Rocket.
I'm glad they don't have to unmute.
The Mantis change feels so good.
I don't know, they adjusted her DPS as well.
But she felt so nice playing.
I was hitting all my shots too.
Even with not with the maximum frames that I used to have on
stream.
They made it so that her damage boosts also have speed
boosts, but she feels so good to play now in terms of
aim-wise.
I was having a good time aiming on her.
I was just hitting my shots.
I was like proud of myself because I was like, yay, I'm not
whiffing.
I was surprised how good we were doing.
because like um because they're doing like triple supports
and stuff so i was like i was proud of us
because you can tell they were they were gaming
oh nice oh my frames are dropping it's still nice
all right well I was super proud of myself for hitting those
shots.
All right.
Oh, nice.
They don't have a hot guy anymore.
I shall no longer be afraid.
I am no longer afraid.
The PCSU gets yourself.
I don't know yet.
We're going to find out here.
We're going to find out.
There we go.
That's right.
What the fuck how?
Wait, wait, what the fuck?
Guys, you're not supposed to die in my health.
Ow!
What's the point of it all?
I should have just used my health to push forward.
Yeah, I was like, guys, my health's on point.
Just let them come over.
I should use the up to push forward.
That was my bad.
I got a little too scared I shouldn't remember in this
yellow.
It's fine to just alt forward because I always feel like you
play like Phoenix or hello Hit scan anything else other than
I can try I Said I'd play DPS and then I realized like
they're all banned I'm just curious This is all he had yet
Anything that will hurt those should tank up monsters right
now.
Oh, that's the got me.
But that's okay.
That's no longer okay.
That's, oh, that was so late.
That was so late, though.
That was such a late up.
Oh my god, just use everything.
Just use everything.
It's okay, it's just him.
Oh, please live there.
Please live, please live, please live, please live, please
live.
Okay.
I just wanted to save our...
Alright.
Oh, I should have used my blind there.
Just live, just live, just live!
How does he have it again?
Oh my god.
I don't know how he just have it again.
42-0s already.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, the whiff!
We all saw it.
Oh, nobody's on Strange.
The portal.
All right, let's hope there's no bucky up.
Talia awkward.
All right, and then...
We didn't ask to be heroes, but we always I wanted to go
cloak but blonde women Try to go cloak a blonde woman moment
There I was like that's cloak right I was just so rushed
Blonde the women am I right guys I was like wait a minute
that's not cloak.
Well, I'm too late the portal the portal was gonna
disappoint So I didn't want to risk it.
I'm so dead.
I was just like, oh shit.
It was just a unfortunate blonde women.
Where I was like, oh shit, wait.
It's not the right one.
I wanted to go cloak.
they are they build up super fast i feel like every fight
they had all i was just like what how did that vault again
okay that was unfortunate that i saw our hella with that
shot apparently we had no dps players there was like oh the
dps i wouldn't play we're all bad and i was like oh rest in
peace bro rest in peace
I was when on cloak it would I don't know maybe I don't know
if it'll help if I was on cloak there
and it was just unfortunate you know what I do wish oh did
you guys see that did you guys see the thing where now let
me play white fox do you guys see the thing where in higher
elo people are paying subscriptions for um for a one trick
or we're basically like or one trick tracker where it
breaches um it breaches the streamer mode and private
profiles of players to uncover like what what characters
they play the most so like people can see like how much play
time you get how much play time you have on each character
even your profile is private that's why it's like a um
that's why it's like a uh that's why you have to It's a paid
subscription and stuff.
And people are using that to gain Elo.
I think that, I don't know.
I do think it's a little cringe to pay a subscription to
gain Elo.
Oh, yeah.
I think if it's free, then it's still a bit cringe.
But if it's free, then like, yeah, it's like, it's free.
People use trackers all the time.
But a paid subscription that can breach private profiles is
like...
Because like...
I've had that.
I had people do that in quickplay um People were like using
a tracker To like look at my like they would like When I was
practicing when I was like just chilling Quickplay I did
like a quickplay Match I don't remember when it was I think
it was a couple of months ago It was a couple of months ago
I was doing quickplay And I was like I was practicing
character Or something for a tournament I think and then
they were like Oh How did you lose?
You're an eternity player And, like, my profile is, like,
extra private.
And, like, you know, they're like, oh, how did you lose on
your main character?
On your main role?
You're on, like, and I was just like, what?
And they didn't know who I was, by the way, because I was on
a...
They didn't know who I was.
Because they were just using the tracker thing.
I'm on my way.
It was so weird.
It just let us.
Yeah, I know, like, other players, they would just do...
I know for other players, they would just have a little
spreadsheet and they'll just memorize levels and banners But
I think it's a little cringe to use like an actual pay
tracker Just for like banning system just streams like the
good old-fashioned way If you're gonna ban people's one
trick just streams like the good old-fashioned way
because they're all streaming it anyway it's not that i'm
endorsing stream sniping but you don't have you know what's
what's free stream sniping that's free but stream snipe
takes effort i do miss the overwatch ones where um oh fuck i
fucked up i fucked up i accidentally dashed in i pressed the
i pressed the e button instead of my shift that was my bad
oh my god of course they have a cloak i'm
not sure the little cloak though i just want to play white
fox you know what no who cares who cares as if it's not the
most optimal support play who cares
oh my god that's so unlucky i was trying to shift onto our
mag, but that's okay.
Who's patty kicking?
Alright, I got him.
I'm gonna save my ship for when I'm this gets dope, or if I
get dope.
A diamond for him.
There we go.
nice that's my simple geometry he's low too I'll use her
other Invis first
I think Daniel seems like is a very when I was playing him
he seems very easy but also I feel like when you figure out
combos and stuff people are gonna it's gonna be like super
broken he is very easy to kill though so you have to be like
he's just an alt battery you have to play like really good
positioning on him on him
who's behind look behind where's behind that's not behind
that was on our side uh he walked to the lip is that where
the fault is I don't oh I hate the it's Why would you, it
blends with the map.
It blended with the map.
Oh, that's, oh, that tilted me.
I was like, where is it?
Oh, we're not going to portal?
That's fine.
It like blended with, I was like, where is it?
Oh, it's the invisible.
I can't see it.
Boom, let's combo.
Pick up your toys, Moon Knight.
I feel renewed.
Bye.
Now play club.
I'm gonna have to use this.
Okay Come come come walk forward
I didn't have to use that.
I just I Did not use that it was just reflex He's not he
just what what folk died in moon.
I don't I don't have it why do we use that this is why I
hate some of the I'm not fast some of the alt FX because
like stuff like that it's so hard like I literally did not
realize that I couldn't find the old holy shit that's so
much damage all right I'm ready to go cloak like the her the
fact that her all blended in with the fucking map itself oh
she's so dead these squids broken the squids are just
killing me i'm working on them whatever i'm there all right
don't worry i got you got you girl
and i'm trying to break the squid don't worry i got you oh
don't worry we also somehow have don't worry i'll break the
arc too don't worry i the support shall break Oh, do not
worry.
I shall break.
Oh, don't worry.
Guess what I'm going to do?
I'm going to break this.
Whoa.
Who said that they're working on it?
Um, I thought they said they were working on breaking.
Oh my god.
Okay.
There's no way I live through that.
It's not dinner time, in fact.
All right, that was a lie.
Did you hear they're like, I'm trying my best to break it?
That was a fucking lie.
I broke every squid.
I was breaking every squid and every, oh my god, quad
support.
Do we just have all support plans?
I
Trying he's walking past them.
I was like that was always a DPS time.
I'm down I'm down to get my shit kicked in
Hey guys look here
Look at that, look at me!
That's a huge ult, though.
That is actually huge.
I'll do it myself.
Alright, I'm gonna go Mantis after this, I feel.
Well, it seems like I'm the only one breaking squad.
They're like, don't worry, guys.
I'm breaking them.
I'm like, um...
So that was a lot.
Okay.
Am I alive?
Here I am.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, I didn't realize there was an enemy cloak.
I got way too confident.
That's okay.
I died on purpose so I can play Mantis!
That's right.
it was a tactical okay maybe not as tactical as I thought
okay
where is my ultra it's
alright he's asleep oh my god there we go that's right I can
aim my gun where the fuck is he There we go Tactical death
seat look at how tactical that was Look at the tactics
All according to plan tactics are working Yeah, it's working
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one life energy is
a powerful weapon against evil all part of the plan I am not
I am not like I may or may not be locked in.
Bump,
bump, bump.
Round two.
Empathy for weakness.
All right, but yeah, it's not eating time, by the way, for
him.
I know it's not.
Wait, how long have I been streaming?
floor okay yeah there's a crash should happen in an hour or
so but if it doesn't if it doesn't guys then i was right i
won't say i told you so dragons but and then i crash and
then and then it's all and then i crash and i lose
Believers, they shot.
Oh, now we don't...
Okay, okay, I didn't realize we are not...
Okay, it's fine.
He still got the heal.
Yeah.
That's nice.
Walk, walk, walk, walk.
Both support's low.
What the fuck?
I'm like...
Alright, guys!
Guys!
What did I say about killing the squid?
say you've been shooting the squids or the eyes.
Okay, I guess today's a Mantis day.
Today I just happened to unlock my third eye when it comes
to Mantis.
I just, apparently, apparently I just know how to aim on
Mantis today.
It's like a little,
All right
All right, guess who's shooting the squid?
Oh shit.
Oh shit, that's fine.
That's fine.
I'm okay.
I'll just live here But okay Like where is she?
Okay, that's good.
I don't have to I missed it Really?
I don't think we need anything here.
Yeah, I was gonna say it.
Alright, nice.
You want...
Honestly?
Well, for me, I never do aim laps.
I just rip it.
By certainly someone else will do it.
Alright, I'll feed.
I'll give that a little treat.
Actually, yeah.
That's awkward for him.
Alright, there we go.
Hello.
Oh my god, hello.
Don't worry!
If I damage boost it, it'll be like 2,200 damage.
Think about it.
If I damage boost it...
Hey buddy.
Oh my god, he's won.
Okay, I made it.
Alright, he'll get his little treat the moment.
The moment!
Dad wins!
As in me, I'm dad now.
Oh my god, he's so hungry.
Oh, man.
Okay, how fucked did I be?
How much am I trolling?
I'm here.
Maybe a lot.
I just looked back.
I was like, my team is so far.
There we go.
Wow, look who I'm shooting at again!
Is that a squid?
He's opening a portal, guys.
Where?
Hey, guys, we should be pushing.
Oh my god!
range i think i'm not or else okay why did that feel so hard
on defense so you be on attack yeah because i'm a mantis
there you go yeah my mantis is demon hours right now yeah
dad behaved during the sponsors like it's over you're not
getting i'm technically there's so many pages i'll go feed
him right now all right
all right i'm at Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I don't know why defense felt so fucking high.
I'm surprised we even had a minute left for that last point.
I thought we were getting rolled.
Not gonna lie.
You know what?
I hit the shots that mattered.
And that's all it is.
Oh, great.
Grand Finals.
There's no way.
Wait, no, that's...
Okay, I thought that was the MRC-MRI banner.
I was like, I think that's for watching.
Right?
Oh, you know what?
It's time.
Oh, you know, it's time.
She's back.
She's got to get as much playtime as possible before we take
her out back and shoot her.
I mean, take her to the farm down safe.
Everything will be fine for her.
It's alright.
She's very much...
I'm very much alive.
And we'll be very much alive tomorrow.
That's tanky.
I came here for tank toky and I got it.
There we go.
Brought her back for one.
last job.
I have
an OTP who?
Which one?
Spider-Man?
Searing.
Oh, Spider-Man.
I was like, which one?
I'm an Invis, so.
I don't remember how to play.
Okay, the issue is I don't remember the combos.
I don't know.
It was like melee.
Okay, shoot melee shield.
Okay, I just don't remember how to...
I don't have it like sec muscle memory.
I'm ready Or Emma I could go Emma actually I'll try strange
if it doesn't work I'll go Emma Because Emma is a lot easier
since it's just tracking It's just aim
Alright The only issue is the pressure of placing a portal I
just don't want them to be mad
okay real what does that mean as long as i maybe i couldn't
all you need to do is capture the mission area got it yeah
all right speed speed hop
All right, the other should not go this way.
Oh, shit.
Hello.
Goodbye.
All right, I'm just gonna...
That's right!
I took out the side!
Oh, God.
Holy shit, I'm just...
One of them... Someone's gonna get the all...
One of the support is getting all soon.
Our support.
Okay, never mind.
Oh, no.
Let's hope.
What's going on?
Oh, my God.
That's actually huge, too.
Goodbye, everybody.
What the fuck is going on?
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to know.
wait where's my supports oh we don't have cloak yet how is
that possible we have all three other support ults there's
just way too much stuff going on my screen not gonna lie
all right oh we lost her we lost i might go emma fuck this
actually
Just Just Don't worry, I got you, bro Maybe not, okay, I
don't think Please alt into the Okay, there you go Okay, I
just needed him to alt into this
Alright, here I'll Sorry, I can't do much other than that I
can't do much other than that guys I I'm going Emma fuck
this Don't mind that's why it feels even more as it's triple
support versus triple support
I'm just gonna go over here I don't think he's okay Okay, I
took it my way.
It's alright.
It was not meant to be.
Tanky might have to be put up next to the barn up stage
soon.
Oh my god.
Get this guy out of here!
Oh my god, please.
Alright, I have...
I have captured her!
Oh my god, please.
We're both impervious.
Oh my god, I hate this cop.
I hate this cop.
I hate triple support so much.
I...
Oh my...
Somebody...
Get this guy out of here.
get this guy out get this get him out of here get him out of
here there
we go
he's so dead i i can't help him there triple support never
look i just don't know how to use her c yeah that's my bad i
didn't know i never used her c before i never had that team
up that privilege there
you go look at all these people look at them look there
we go I'll take those oh my god this is bad for me
it almost worked though it almost worked oh my god I was
about to grab her too
I'm so sad.
I was about to grab her.
Where are they?
Where?
What's going on?
What?
Do we have all?
Do we have another all?
Please!
Kill her!
Oh, my!
Okay.
Alright.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
nice all right i don't know what's going on i just hope
something is happening i just hoping something is happening
i why do you feel like nobody plays tank for enjoyment
everyone who plays tank enjoys the pain and suffering the
sick But they just loved the pain and suffering.
They're all M's.
I refuse to believe that they play this role for pleasure.
It's never for pleasure.
They just want to feel the pain.
They want to feel...
The pain and suffering.
Why is there a fucking thing?
Okay.
Am I... Where are they?
Oh my god, they're so low.
I was trying to...
I really want to kill the Phoenix right now.
Oh my god, he's so low, he's so low.
Oh my god, what is...
I'm putting that here, just in case.
We got him!
Just get him!
Alright, it's fine.
We got him.
We got him, guys.
It's okay.
Beat his ass!
Do it!
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
Diamond of snow and all that jazz, you know?
There you are.
I've protected him.
Don't worry, I'll be your hero.
Okay, that's fine.
Alright.
Okay.
What's going on?
Just kill him.
Beat his ass.
That's what you do it.
Are they just portaling?
I think they're portaling.
That won't turn down extra protection.
There's no way, right?
That's a little tall.
All right, that's bad.
We both fucked up.
How?
Oh my god.
The Strange and I both sort of fucked up the the alts there.
We both fucked up alts.
It's okay.
A Strange managed to build another alt soon.
I'm so sad.
We could have we almost got that alt.
We almost got...
Kill the supports.
Oh, what the fuck?
I lost Ultron and that's a little worrying stuff.
I don't like that.
Oh!
I'm just gonna back out a little bit, yeah.
This is bad because the moment they have...
Oh my god.
i'm trying bro
oh my god oh that was huge that is a huge alt
it's okay they don't have that all okay we have five alts
for the last fight
this place is worth a good luck my revenge
luna you all first a shortcut through space I'm doing this
at a moment at three.
Oh, we both used it at the same time.
All right, there you go.
That's fine.
I got the support.
That's equivalent exchange.
It's equivalent exchange.
Good trade.
It is.
All right, their invis is coming back.
I got one of their supports.
So honestly, I take those.
What the fuck?
Somebody kill the other one.
My.
Here we go.
Good trade!
I will block them!
Get over!
Good trade!
Oh my god.
Oh.
I think I got carried by a strange.
I think.
Oh my god.
No, that's fine.
No, we got, you know what?
Our damage were similar.
Okay, maybe he had more fun of those.
Oh my, I hate Tink.
I hate Tink Tink so much.
We got good trade.
Hey, maybe a little carried.
Hey, look, a win's a win.
A win's a fucking win.
Oh, I fucking hate triple support so much.
Oh, my God, it's so miserable.
It's so miserable.
It's just me being like, is anything happening?
Is anything dying?
I don't know.
Something's working.
I...
It's like...
Is anything dying, guys?
Is it...
Now, who am I gonna banish from this match?
It's not different.
It's all...
I just hate triple support.
It doesn't matter what role I play.
It's just not a fun experience.
It feels like everybody's just...
alive forever oh yeah yeah I'm done I'm done with the
sponsored portion yeah now it's a free for all are they
dying guys guys I'm creating space what's going on in the
back line we're all dead oh that's usually how it goes am I
creating space guy oh you're all oh we're all dead all right
we're all dead oh
we're running triple all right guess what it's triple time
oh
let's go triple triple triple
All right, here we go.
At least Matt just clicks heads.
That's true.
That is true.
Oeeeeee.
I can't wait.
I'm super excited trying to do a PC setup.
That means I can actually play, like, shooter games with
optimal frames.
Because, you know, when I stream, like, rivals and stuff, I
get, like, 100 to, like, 100 frames, which isn't great.
Like, it drops to 100.
Like, you can see it's at 150, but it drops to 100.
But on off-stream, obviously, I get, like, 300-ish frames
when I play off-stream.
Goodbye, Emma.
It's going to be very exciting.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Hit him up!
It doesn't stop.
Oh wait, maybe it does stop.
Oh my god, you got fully healed already.
Alright.
Where's my other...
Oh wait, we're duo support?
Okay, I was gonna help him, but then he shot him already.
Alright, this is not great.
Because there's not a lot of heals.
doing that oh my god he got pulled away that's unfortunate
that's unfortunate all right i didn't realize we're running
i didn't realize when did we swap off triple you just gotta
shoot the healer bro you guys are keep you guys keep
fighting the two tanks oh the healer's right there
all right here you go
Why are you so mad?
It's the end of season.
You know what you're getting into on end of seasons, guys.
You can't be mad when you know what games you're getting.
Yeah.
I think we need to peel more, that's for sure.
Don't worry, I'm peeling this time.
I have to be mad.
It's only a game.
it was but like you should know like the type of players
you're getting you know you know what I mean when you're
like when we play end of season you know it's gonna be a
free-for-all I'm
just gonna try and be like next year wait that's right oh
hello that's right where's her white box oh there she is
there she is what the where am i what's going on
oh god oh there's a fucking okay i did not see the i don't
see her behind me Lightning, give a Twitch Prime, thank you.
I think we win this.
Oh, what's happening?
I got thrown up into the air eight times.
Am I winning?
Oh, hey.
That's in the air, like eight times.
It's my own little rollercoaster.
There's so much CC now.
I think that's an issue with a lot of games as they get
older.
They're like, what abilities do we add?
And it's just like a cluster fuck of CCs.
Because it's like at some point you're just gonna run out of
ideas.
Don't worry, I got you!
Oh, not her though.
I didn't talk about her.
But I got the other.
Oh, not.
Maybe, maybe.
I got you, though.
Alright.
I got you.
Oh, not him though.
Not him.
Unless, unless, unless, unless, still, nope, not him
anymore.
Guys, we gotta stop pushing it.
Guys.
Is he gonna live?
Yeah, he lives.
You know what?
Watch this.
Boom!
Alright, nice.
I'll take this.
Yeah, it's all up.
She's looking for it.
Look at her.
This is right.
Oh.
White Fox.
That might not have been the all you think it was gonna be.
Oh, White Fox.
Mafia's coolest and all that you thought it was.
Karak, thank you for the super...
Oh, that's right.
Think of the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
They should have job application time.
It's so you have them live.
Think of the super...
Fuck, yes!
Sorry.
I'm YouTube brain right now.
Think of the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
I'm just...
I'm just YouTube brain at the moment.
It's been a while since I've been on Twitch, guys.
Please understand.
The super bitties.
It is pretty super.
I think they have super...
portals every time i used my own they would have a luna orb
i feel it i think this is a loseable game
but it's okay i blinded the flock what's he gonna do
okay i blinded the fox holy shit oh no
He blocked me
Where's the portal it didn't I she was in my fucking alt for
two slashes and it didn't slash her that's you that's a GG's
right there, bro That's an insane GG's right there.
Holy fuck So he's so angry handed the sky a life like that's
it's it's incredible how that just happened Check the vase
Man's angry.
He's okay.
What do you think?
The vibes are out.
He's...
You think he needs a little snack?
He needs a little break?
Does Matt need a little hug?
DPS players when they don't get anything they ever...
They want ever.
It's so true.
He's like...
He asks for heals and he doesn't get...
it in one second it's like healer diff healer diff support
diff
where are my heels
where's dd dinosaur when you need him so true guys where is
he how will we win without him
Three, two, one.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
All right.
Pre-healing.
Pre-heal.
All right, we're on.
Oh, where's our tanks?
Our poor Punisher is getting his shit kicked in right now.
He's like, all right, guys.
You guys ready?
All right.
And, oh, whoa.
I gotta pull back.
The front and back turn into a back and back.
Okay, I have my right click, guys.
It's okay.
Oh, my God.
I jumped up when I was trying to...
It's okay.
See, everything is fine.
No, everything is no longer.
Guys, guys.
Everything is no longer.
Oh, my God.
Where am I?
Okay, everything is fine.
Wait, I lived.
Alright.
I did not expect to live that.
I legitimately thought I was gonna die.
I was literally running around the pillar, hoping that that
is enough diversion.
Oh, hey, Heavenly!
What's your rank right now?
You think this game is hard now?
Get ready for season eight.
I used to be free, Lil.
Oh no, what happened?
I might have an account, Heavy.
I might have to look around, though.
I might have an account.
Why are there three people over there?
Oh, my God.
Never mind.
Yeah, but they're...
But remember, they're Lord in Platte.
Okay, that's why I'm gonna have to freeze all of his life.
Is he gonna ult me?
Oh, I try to save you.
I'm sorry.
Don't worry, I'm still...
I'm in this corner.
My little corner hole.
It's five.
Whoa!
Wait, did no one portal?
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Hey, I'm back.
I'm back, baby.
Oh, nice.
Stand in my...
Oh, or not.
Don't worry.
You don't need to stand in my bubble.
My bubble doesn't matter.
I won't let my...
Why would you up the...
Oh.
I was gonna say, why would you up?
Okay, we're gonna have to let our...
That's a bad job, thanks.
A little health pack.
Okay, he almost has all, so I'm gonna...
I'm just gonna hope for the best.
Oh, please.
No.
Bro, the alt didn't reach me.
Oh, my God.
That's so unlucky.
I'm trying so hard to keep him up.
Good kill.
You're so hot.
I was just going to shoot this.
Yeah, shoot the goddamn Loki clone.
I'm not chasing me around the map, dude.
I can't play the game.
Oh, God, please.
Oh, God, you wanted to kill me so bad.
Oh, my God, please.
Have mercy on me.
Come where I got you.
How is it still going?
This might be where I die.
Oh my god.
Rocket.
You're so...
No!
We're so close.
Let's try my best to keep the rocket alive.
I mean, I'll take that.
I'll take that.
You know what?
The log is over time.
The rocket just got...
I tried my best to let her heal, but then I was like, people
are dying.
I can't.
That was the longest overtime fight of my life.
And then we got, like, way too cocky there.
How did he...
Oh, he got out of the range.
Just there.
As we're missing aim.
Oh, never mind.
Because I hope he...
They do have a Spider-Man on.
They're my best.
to keep him up.
He did use it super early, so.
I'm just gonna let him.
Yeah, I didn't wanna...
Hello?
Get ready for...
Oh, never mind.
I was getting ready for the ult.
We have, technically, one fight.
Oh my god, get out!
Leave me alone
Here I got you like leave me alone
Wait, their Hulk is Never mind their Hulk is no longer
fucked up Oh my god, literally just come back.
I literally just came back that sucks
Okay, we lost We lost.
He was so one that I had to reload.
We lost.
No!
Wow,
wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Unlucky.
I had to reload.
I had to reload and I put it at 1 HP.
If anyone else shot her, she'd have died.
Unlucky.
I had an idea that it wasn't winnable.
How it feels getting cared.
Oh my god.
Report the spot.
Wait.
You're right.
Look at that.
Holy shit.
The fact that the Scarlet Witch did more than the spot of
it.
Can't even be bad at a game.
Without getting reported.
Fine, final hit, Spidey.
I want to say, let's see, what count do I have?
I think I have a, I think I have a silver account.
I don't have Heavenly still here.
I think I have a silver account, Heavenly.
I think.
I just have to dig through my accounts.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Yeah, what is it?
I might just be, don't worry.
Everybody's washed.
It's end of season.
We're all washed.
It's okay.
We're on silver.
How bad could you do against silver players, Heavenly?
Just imagine.
How bad could you really do in silver?
Wait, can silver players queue at Platts?
Oh, wait.
I actually don't know.
Get Silver Players Q with Plats.
Can anyone fact check that?
Do you think you're going to go Gambit or should we ban him?
If you go Gambit, we get to go Gambit.
Yeah, I feel like I have it.
After this game, I'll check.
I'm just going to ban Group.
I'll check after this game.
And so everybody's watched if they're in Plats, heavily.
Bum, bada.
All right, I'll check.
Oh, I forgot who to ban.
I only play DPS Luna.
Ooh.
All right.
Oh, we didn't ban Gambit.
It's Gambit time.
But did we not ban...
We did not ban Loki either.
It's Gambit time.
He thanks you.
All right, here we go.
No problem, guys.
That'll be the one to get it, Doug, from Steve.
You sound like that for real?
Oh, so deaf.
That's I know you're lying.
You have no buddies.
I am his buddy.
I'm actually his buddy.
That's my buddy.
Don't talk to my buddy like that.
Yeah, don't talk to him.
Yeah, don't talk to him either.
my child like that my child's child I've been never foots
I've been running gather enough oh they're running
wolves though oh there was no saving him there was no he
kidnapped oh nope gambit never folds
you're ready guys which support is gonna swap the low key
first let's find out oh that was a huge add detail
that's why you can't grip me that's right can't grip me okay
he might if he grips me a a third time he can't he might be
able to grip me there is a chance where he will grip me that
was a huge anti too I can't keep you up bro are we doing
triple no we're doing DPS pool okay I was gonna say is a
triple tank pool
Guys, we gotta stop getting kidnapped.
We're so helpful.
Please let me have a...
Get out of here!
That's fucking right.
Alright, now...
Gambit never falls!
Alright, now they have Gambit never falls and then we'll be
fucked.
They didn't use anything.
We do have Cloakos.
They have all of us.
They have everything.
They didn't use anything.
Hello.
No, but.
Hey, Cloak, you already have all.
They
kill people?
Nice.
What the fuck happened in that corner?
I couldn't see I was too short.
all right i wonder what it would be like to have 200 frames
on stream there you go all right they have all the arena in
the same spot here for turns he looks like he's gonna hold
oh there's our poke up there we go oh there i go There we
go, and there I go.
Wait, what happened to the street?
Oh, fuck me, I guess.
The street gets to live?
Oh, just because I'm your husband, I have to die?
Only you.
That's fuck.
Just because we're married.
It was boring.
See what I'm saying?
it was so low there was so many there's so many pixels on my
screen right now
well make sure these guys are yeah I feel he wanted to grip
me what the fuck are cloak already has another hook the
current score is She can't have you talking to other girls.
Look, look, I was just talking to Dagger because she dropped
her pencil and I picked it up for her.
It was all that is.
I swear.
She bent down because she was going to grab her pencil and I
grabbed it for her.
Show him what the fuck you is, Nick.
Listen, my buddy, you get to clobber.
Wait, what's that?
Do you know, like, if you say the gamer word on NBC, rivals
insta-hit you of a mute, and I think they might have
insta-hit him before you could finish his sentence.
I...
Come here, strange.
Let me bounce on you.
Do you truly believe you can stop my...
You get...
There's like an algorithm that auto-detects it and you get
instamuted the moment you say it.
Oh, no!
They surrendered.
Yay!
That's what you get for not banning Gambit.
Another epic victory!
Big win!
Yeah, I know that because there was a clip of...
There was a clip where two players were like, Wait, you're
black?
He's like, I'm black too.
And then they just said the N-word to each other.
And then they both got insta-muted.
They're like, yo.
And then, you know.
And then they both got muted.
It was a funny clip.
And the other guys are like, Don't say it.
Don't say it.
No, why did I say it?
I'm going to get muted now.
all right let me let me see if i have an account evenly all
right let me double check
all right come on rivals come on all right i don't know if i
have to dig through my archives for this Let's see.
It could be this.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, let me try and find the password.
It has been so long since I've logged into this account that
it requires me to put in the password again.
Who did I send this info to?
Not you.
You?
Oh, there you go.
I found.
Okay, let's see.
Remember me, please.
Wait,
I don't have, oh no, wait, because I don't think I have
access to this account anymore.
I might not have, I might not, I might not have access to
this particular account anymore.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me double check.
I think I got like Oh Wait No Let me see I have another one
I might have another one
Wait actually
I need to check the email For it It has been a while Since
I've been on that account Oh my It might be gone
okay wait unless i do have another one i do have another one
let me try and find it i have i do have multiple accounts i
just haven't logged into a lot of them in a while
let's see uh
to find it i'm sad oh wait that okay wait let me see if it
still exists give me a sec i'm trying to remember guys you
guys remember all my alt account names because i don't does
anyone remember because i don't
didn't i have i'm pretty sure i have it was i don't well
everybody knows oh i don't know do i still have number i
think i'm number two number two dokey bird fan right because
someone took number one didn't someone took number one
it's been so long
all right let's see trying to find it heavenly i do have
other accounts i'm just trying to figure out where it is
this is my main but i'm just trying to
okay it's this one i'm trying to see if they still exist
i don't write them down i just have i just have like i have
a pin somewhere um in my thing okay number two dokey bird
fan okay that doesn't exist wait was it number two dokey
bird fan okay that doesn't exist number one dokey bird fan
that's not me That's not me.
That's an imposter.
Wait, is it me?
Wait, that... That's not me.
Is it me?
That's not me.
Is it?
I... It's not me.
It's not me.
I'm not... Oh, it's not me.
It's John.
It's... It's John.
I was like, is it?
I can't remember.
me okay let me grab I have a list here what do you six I
don't remember I don't remember well there's no number two
jokie bird fan what happened I must have name changed it all
right let's see um when was this I'm trying to find and now
guys don't worry I must have an account it must exist
somewhere in this world yeah
which one is this and which one is this all right we're
gonna oh oh all right we're gonna try this what is this
sorry that's my overwatch account wait okay all right we're
gonna try this one I have info all right we're gonna try
this one
actually it's odd for us I'm like do I actually all right
add account does it work oh okay it might work yeah i might
have access to it maybe i'll
just sign into this email please confirm login i have to do
capture now oh my god what the fuck is this capture
it's like please click the tile that changes i fuck they
invent like new ways for captures
all these new fangle captures now to make sure i am human
And I absolutely am human.
All right, where is it?
Enter your code.
Where?
Where's my code?
Oh, it's in spam.
Wait, it's in trash?
Oh, it's in social.
It's a back and forth.
Why did I...
I think where is the game oh yeah it's on the last place it
should be all right before let me make sure this is a right
account all right let's make sure this account works guys
because I don't know
what the fuck
i think i guys
whoops this might not be my account
i think i actually took someone this might be someone else
is like oh i'll figure it out here this might not be my
account i was like i was like looking at it i was like why
do i have this account info whose account is this I will
know the moment I see the name yeah the moment I see it how
did you do that whose account is this oh I know who's
account this is okay I know whose account this is all right
I'm in I'm accidentally in I don't know I think I know I
also don't know I don't know how I got in my list of
accounts I think I might have actually put the list their
account in here oops that is my bad I didn't mean to put
their account in here I'm just yoying my account now all
right wait what look what you know is this heavenly what
plot what plot are you heavenly what plot are you
i need a no you're gonna use it bro left probably left it
took too long to grab the account here's like that girl that
that fish is not gonna have an account i'm leaving
I lost the other one.
Yeah, what plaid are you?
I need to know.
Because this one's diamond one.
It's diamond one.
It's not plaid.
So we're going to put...
I know you said you were washed, but we might go into
diamond, Yulum.
Thank God.
Did his ass fall asleep?
Oh my...
Alright, time to swap accounts.
after all this work wait I might have another account I
think I know whose account it is and you had to message them
and be like they actually sign into your alt account it's
someone else's alt account and I think I accidentally signed
into their alt account because it was in my list I was like
that has to be mine right
I don't know It was on my list of alt accounts
I think it used to be mine And I gave it away Because I was
like I don't play I don't play as much rivals anymore So I
was there like Oh I was just like I'm not I don't use it
anymore
And then like And I was like That's why I dug so hard I was
like oh I found it I found another account I can use
and i was like oh yeah i i gave that one away like like year
plus ago that was how long it was i was like dude oh man i
must be able to use that one
he's gone all right back to back to gm lobbies
i mean i could you know what i could do i can literally
message him What plat...
Are you...
Like...
Okay, I messaged him.
Oh, we're back.
He had a heart attack.
I'm sure we can get GM too.
Are you gonna play a mixtape?
A masterpiece?
I can... I'm gonna watch mixtape.
You mean... you mean watch?
Mac mixtape
it's more I will say it's definitely more of a visual novel
which hero do you think you want to be today all right
this time I'll play white Fox for real and I won't swap for
sure it's not gonna gonna happen this time
wait starting today channel points, emotes, subs, bits and
badges are available to all streamers on Twitch.
Oh, that's nice.
That's sweet.
They changed the uh it's that bottom of plat.
Okay.
Unfortunately sad face next season we duo my lowest is
diamond one
next season is like in two days he's black three or four
I can I can do a next season which is technically in two
days all that search for nothing pick your hero or villain
i'm not judging all right here we go
white fox rocket i mean we have gambit fans it shouldn't be
that bad
director han white fox let's make this quick and clean i
mean i really want i can just hand level i can hand level a
unranked account.
Did you hear about the the freshie account thing with
Overwatch?
Where like if you go in if you do an uh if you Go in and do
placements on a fresh new account you can get placed in
champ or GM And then like People got really mad because like
Uh, those people got who got placed in GM or champ are like
diamond or master players So like they've never been GM or
champ before and they were getting placed in like champ and
GM lobbies After placements and people were getting really
pissed off because obviously it's like, you know affecting
Wait, are we?
Okay Because it's like affecting people's matches
So when you have a fresh year account, it's like GG's on
your team
Because they're not supposed to be in that elo but for some
reason they aren't.
Yeah, because it's like, it's literally reverse smurfing.
The people got where we're getting, like, really pissed off
about it.
Like, they changed something.
They changed something with the...
With, like, placement matches somehow.
He's so healthy.
Oh, I'm so excited for Dual PC.
I'm so excited.
I've been, like, on doing that because I keep thinking as
long as I have a beefy PC everything will be fine but
everything was not fine and I've given up I've I've finally
decided to try a dual PC set up and I want to know what it's
like to stream with with so with lots of frames and be able
to play with lots of frames also I've always get like
worried I would fuck up dual PC because I don't know much
but I was like fuck this I'm actually gonna do it I'm always
worried that I'm gonna mess it up
surprise Fox surprise Fox shouldn't have grabbed me Fox go
away surprise Fox leave now oh surprise Fox might be what
oh we don't have
Oh my god, there.
Rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket,
rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket.
There you go.
Oh yeah, and also because the other reason why I haven't
done it is because of RAM prices.
But RAM prices are starting to go down.
Oh yeah.
My room might turn into a sauna, so I might look into
getting an extra portable air conditioning.
Just so like I don't burn in my room.
That was another reason why I didn't want to do a dual PC
setup.
But now RAM prices are starting to go down now.
Because AI companies are going bankrupt.
Yay!
I can buy RAM again!
Yippee!
Ramp!
We can buy RAM!
Yay!
The purple is popping!
Yeah, I'm definitely going to try and get a...
I'm going to get a portable air conditioning.
Because I don't want to...
I don't want to, like, up...
I do have air conditioning, but I don't want to up it.
It controls my entire apartment.
And dad, I don't want to, like, make it too cold for dad
because he's a short-haired, weenor dog.
So it's not going to be great for him.
Like, yeah, I could get him, like, more blankets, but I'd
rather he be comfortable, you know?
I just want him to be comfortable.
That's right.
Oh, hello.
Get Fox.
Yeah, but I just don't want it to be, like, too cold for
him.
Get over here!
Stop walking away!
you yeah I get it myself a portable air conditioning and
then dad gets a portable heater to counteract each other
yeah stop running just accept your death I'm gonna let Rocky
heal more because I don't need to heal anyone oh that's sad
get well get Fox boom Boom, boom, boom, boom, oh, goodbye.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, that's so awkward.
Maybe I should not.
Sorry, guys.
I got too greedy.
I just, they were just standing there.
I just wanted to stomp on them with my fox paws.
Can you blame me?
The greed.
I actually, we lost that fight because of me.
I was like, oh my god, but what if I just stomp?
They're so stompable.
Oh my god, that's fine.
Is that where he lives?
Okay, that's where he lives.
He doesn't know I'm here.
Oh, he does.
I am ready to put on a show.
It's fine.
There's so many particles on my screen, but everything is
fine.
Stop running away!
Okay, wait, wait, back.
Leave me.
Leave.
No, no, no, no.
You can't run away.
Keep running away.
Oh, that's huge.
That's actually huge.
There we go.
We're good.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Very good.
Our Captain America was good in terms of, like, they were a
really good distraction.
Okay, but what if I start stomping again?
Yay!
Easy.
Finally.
Finally, I can play a full White Fox game.
That's all I wanted.
Wait,
they went triple support.
It's dying.
I didn't see it.
It's finally happening.
Triple support is finally dying out.
Guys.
I don't want to say I told you so.
I don't want to say it.
But, okay, honestly, maybe it's a YouTube.
Maybe it's a YouTube.
YouTube I'll start crashing again maybe it's a but but I
downgraded my drivers back to 2025 July and feels like it
feels like things are going okay right now we're not tank
players it's time i really don't want to actually don't jinx
it don't keep
me now crash your pc
all i'm saying is that it's pretty odd that it's
that I'm not crashing right now hmm all right this might be
LG
I only did a long stream because I really wanted to I wanted
to I just wanted to stress test the PC to see how long, see
how far we can go.
Alright.
Ah, fuck it.
Let's go.
LG with Emma, because I do enjoy Emma.
Alright, here we go.
Tank bird is...
Tanky bird is back.
30 seconds before you Tamer man.
Oh, because we had a Spider-Man.
We had a Scooter man.
Plan what tanky bird.
We got, we revived here for one more game.
One last run.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
Here we go.
Either I'm gonna get yelled at.
Or nobody cares what I do.
What?
Oh my god, it's fucking on.
Sorry, I should have...
I just wanted to shoot the on.
Because no one ever shoots the on.
Okay, that's bad.
That's why you don't get to come over here.
Oh my god, I knew he was gonna grab me too.
Oh, wait, where's my heal?
Oh.
Where's my cloak doing?
That's alright, we're still...
We saw at the point.
Alright, it's fine.
We still at the point.
I'm actually playing an autopilot.
right now I'm not I should be trying more I may or may not
be autopiloting come on
you know you want to come over here you know you want to
come over here what the fuck get out of here oh we lost
there we lost our other dive the
fuck is What's going on?
There we go.
That's how I feel whenever I'm playing with a dive team.
Like, what the fuck is...
I mean, that works!
Like, that's fine.
Thanks, Cloak.
I think the Cloak wanted to ult.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure I accidentally grabbed her while she was
trying to...
Yeah, I was like, why are you there?
Why are you so close?
Your support.
I was like, I mean, that'll do.
I was like, I mean, sure.
That's a better trade.
Get down, Mr. President.
I'm pretty sure she was really...
There was no way for, there was no reason for it to be right
next to her, Emma.
What the?
You know what?
I'm not surprised that it's from Miss Animathize.
Whoa.
Where, is the spotty in the room right now?
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
all you need to do is capture the missionary what got it
you're like i'll save my odds i feel like every i feel like
everybody's gonna just we're gonna chuck five alts into the
game
unless i could
oh that's huge
yep there it is i made them use two ups i mean that's the
Get him!
Where's our fox?
Our fox is dead.
Oh, unlucky.
Unlucky.
They just threw more ults in than us.
They did use... I mean, they use all their support ults, so
that's fine.
But we...
1-0 for 3?
Um...
It does look like we did use three ults.
We also used three ults.
We just didn't use Hulk.
Noink.
That's fine.
I have my own.
Nice.
All right.
Get tracked.
Noink.
That's what...
which side I was on.
Sometimes you just forget, okay?
I was like, what side am I on again?
Where does the enemy come out?
I wonder where.
I guess I'll never know.
Get over here!
No!
Get it!
That's right!
Get over here!
Yeah!
You didn't tell when I started mailing, I just like jiggled
my mouse everywhere.
I'm like, I don't know.
I hope I'm hitting them.
I'm just like, well, I'll be able to get to the point.
I was like, surely that'll hit him.
Someone's running to point.
Don't worry, we're so healthy.
Oh, boom!
Can't jump forever, Captain.
Maybe you can.
Can't jump forever.
Oh my god.
Guys, he might be able to jump forever.
He actually might.
He actually jumped forever.
He...
He jumped forever.
Maybe he can.
And maybe he can jump forever and running.
Oh wait, okay.
They're not touching.
He can do this all day.
America does not skip League Day.
Oh, today I found out.
I can't believe it.
He jumped out of my own.
we end on tank i mean we got a good run we ranked up i
definitely got carried by my hawk player but hey at least i
i was i was there for the front line you know i helped i
helped secure i helped anchor the front line all right i'm
gonna call you guys no crashes so far and that's pretty
positive we're gonna check i guess we'll see you tomorrow
how it goes on Um, actually, no, I guess we'll see on Friday
if everything is gonna wait.
What am I streaming on Friday?
Oh, we'll see on Friday if everything will be okay on
YouTube.
But currently no crashes, which is pretty positive, positive
outcome.
Thank you all for coming on the stream.
Thank you to my rivals for the sponsor.
Like I said, we want to support the stream.
We support the sponsor.
We want to support my rivals.
Please feel free to click on the link.
You can play my rivals right now for free.
It does support me and the stream and the sponsor a lot.
Um, anyway, guys, for those who are new here, My name is
Doki Bird.
I usually stream on the YouTubes, but I'm here for the
sponsor today.
Usually I stream, like, guerrilla stuff.
So if I have nothing, it's, like, basically not on the
schedule, type streams will be on Twitch.
So if you want to know whenever I stream on Twitch, please
feel free to check out my Twitter.
Exclamation point, Twitter, socials.
You want to support me with other means?
I have merch right now.
So, exclamation point, merch.
Check out the store.
It does support me as well.
And, but, but, but, I have all these codes.
Gamer subcodes, Doki Bird, Fortnite code.
Doki Bird, EA Code, Doki Bird, all the codes, everything.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture
checked, get up, and move around to get that blood flow.
And you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
Oh, yes, songs.
Girlfriend is back on Spotify.
Again, we re-uploaded the song.
I don't know if I'm going to strike myself down again, but
the song is back on Spotify, back on streaming services.
I haven't tweeted it out because I wanted to see if it will
get taken down before I tweeted it out.
but you can stream the stuff you can stream the cover now
it's back on streaming services we just re-uploaded it so
we'll see any guys i'll see you guys later everybody bye
guys bye